mais on voit cet amendement 424 avec
deux avis défavorables qui est pour
qui est contre
qui s'abstient il n'est pas adopté nous
passons à l'article 9 avec une motion
5392 tendon renvoie en commission
c'est madame pomirol qui défend cette
notion
merci monsieur le président
c'est les sénateurs du groupe socialiste
écologiste républicains demande le
renvoie en commission de cet article 9
portant sur l'usure professionnelle en
effet les dispositions contenues dans
cet article ne sont pas à la hauteur des
besoins des salariés en matière de
reconnaissance et de compensation de la
pénibilité je voudrais d'abord insister
sur le changement de sémantique puisque
nous parlons nous de pénibilité qui
induit une responsabilité collective
liée aux conditions de travail vous
introduisez aujourd'hui notion d'usure
professionnelle qui renvoie une
responsabilité individuelle ce qui est
très différent cet article constitue en
outre la profondeur du délai tricotage
massif de la prise en compte de la
pénibilité engagée par le Président de
la République Emmanuel Macron dès son
premier quinquennat en 2017 les quatre
facteurs de pénibilité supprimés en 2017
ne sont pas réintégrés ici
ni les postures pénibles ni les
vibrations mécaniques ni la manutention
de charges lourdes ni les agents
chimiques dangereux mais les
travailleurs usés par ce type de
pénibilité aurait droit à une visite
médicale à 61 ans soit quelques mois
avant une hypothétique retraite
anticipée et cela si tenté que la
médecine du travail soit mesure de
l'appliquer de plus la cotisation
spécifique qui vise à inciter les
employeurs à réduire l'exposition de
leurs salariés à des facteurs de risque
a été définitivement abandonné plutôt
que de prévenir activement les
mécanismes de pénibilité au travail le
gouvernement préfère donc les constater
en fin de carrière quand il est déjà
trop tard et qu'on travaille ailleurs a
subi la pénibilité de te rendre toute sa
carrière alors que ce qui serait
important ce serait de regarder toujours
la prévention en traitant des conditions
de travail
aussi nous pensons qu'il faut de nouveau
étudier en entièrement ce problème de la
pénibilité et c'est pour cela que nous
demandons un renvoi en commission
merci chers collègues
madame a rapporteur ou monsieur
rapporteur pendant sur ce renvoie
défavorable défavorable monsieur le
ministre même avis donc je mets la
motion voix avec deux avis défavorables
qui est pour
qui est contre
qui s'abstient
elle n'est pas adoptée à la présidente
la commission
merci monsieur le Président en
application de l'article 46 bis alinéa 2
du règlement la Commission demande un
examen séparé de l'amendement 21-32 des
rapporteurs et en application l'article
44 à 6 de règlement nous demandons
également la priorité d'examen de votre
sur cet amendement merci monsieur le
ministre
sagesse donc il y a pas d'opposition du
gouvernement donc la priorité est
ordonnée
il y a une demande de priorité sur
l'amendement
2132 de la part de la Commission afin
qu'il soit mis au voie en premier avant
l'ensemble des amendements de l'article
donc il est dans l'alliance le 2132 de
la Commission
c'est en cours de distribution
on attend on attend la distribution
merci monsieur le Président rappelle au
règlement s'il vous plaît selon
l'article 46 bis vous demandez de bien
vouloir nous laisser une petite minute
pour prendre
non seulement conscience on va dire des
conséquences que la présidente de la
commission vient d'annoncer en donnant
priorité sur un amendement et donc avec
les conséquences que cela et
bouleversant l'ordre de l'examen des
amendements prévus est-ce que vous
voulez bien rappeler excusez-moi
pouvez-vous rappeler ou madame la
Présidente pour vous rappeler ce que la
Commission propose sur le l'ordre
d'examen des amendements s'il vous plaît
alors moi j'étais saisi d'une demande de
priorité sur l'amendement 2132 de la
commission qui a dû être en cours de
distribution
donc alors madame la Présidente oui
merci merci monsieur le Président bon on
a pas l'amendement mais on voit bien ce
qui est ce qu'on essaye de de tramer en
proposant cette cette priorité sur cette
amendement de 1132 qui arrive quand même
loin dans l'examen de cet article 9 donc
sur la base de ce que vient de dire ma
collègue nous demandons parce que nous
avons besoin de retravailler puisque
nous avions un certain nombre
d'amendements qui précédait cet
amendement de Monsieur Savary nous
demandons une suspension de saison de
séance car nous avons besoin nous aussi
de travailler de réfléchir à une à une
un autre au développement
alors si je peux terminer si je peux
terminer terminer ma phrase simplement
donc je le redis demandez une suspension
de séances pour permettre à mon groupe
de pouvoir travailler bah oui mais
écoutez vous avez vu aussi tuer la
demande en 2132 dans la dans la liasse
vous avez vu le nombre d'abonnements que
nous avons et qui précède cet amendement
donc nous avons besoin de travailler
nous sommes des gens sérieux et
responsables et nous avons besoin de
travailler donc suspension de séance
merci maman présidente le président
Gontard oui merci un rappel un règlement
sur l'article 44 bis de la même manière
et ce qui a été dit je demandais
également à voir un peu de temps pour
conserver organise effectivement on voit
bien la manipulation mais le fait de
faire remonter cette cette amendement
forcément ça nous déstabilise il faut
bien qu'on se réorganise bah oui si
c'est une c'est une réalité franchement
je sais pas comment vous arrivez vous
m'expliquerez comment vous arrivez à
travailler dans ces conditions là mais
je pense que franchement ça manque un
petit peu de sérieux quand même ça
manque un petit peu de sérieux donc
c'est très bien on agite l'article 38 on
agit de ça mais quand même ça manque
réellement de sérieux donc moi je
demande à ce qu'on est une suspension de
séance qu'on puisse s'organiser et qu'on
puisse repartir sur des basses saines
comme on vient de le faire jusqu'à
présent merci et à monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Président canner
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre
depuis quelques heures même quelques
jours vous nous accusez de toutes les
turpitudes
de toutes les turpitudes voire même de
je ne sais pas quoi
mélenchonisation c'est cela
je vous le dis très simplement
merci d'être finalement en conformité
avec le travail qui doit se poursuivre
au Sénat sur l'examen de ce projet de
loi
ne soyez pas
déloyaux vis-à-vis de votre position
mais oui vous êtes
déloyaux puisque un travail a été fait
d'ordonnancement de nos amendements et
manifestement vous voulez couper court à
ce travail par cette priorisation donc
elle est potentiellement bien sûr tout à
fait réglementaire et légal je dis
simplement que vous contribuez
manifestement par ce type de manoeuvre
non pas finalement à de l'obstruction
mais à du sabotage d'un bon travail
parlementaire
merci chers collègues
alors mes chers collègues
s'il vous plaît un petit peu d'attention
je vais accorder cinq minutes de
suspension de séance
attendez attendez attendez mais avant je
voudrais préciser je vous repréciser un
petit peu les choses donc j'ai été saisi
d'une priorité d'une demande de priorité
de la part la Commission le gouvernement
a donné un avis de sagesse et j'ai donc
ordonné cette priorité par ailleurs en
application de l'article 46 bis alinéa 2
du règlement je suis saisi d'une demande
de la commission d'examen séparé de son
amendement 2132 l'article 9 donc je dois
consulter le Sénat sur cette demande
donc qui est pour cet examen séparé
qui est contre
donc la demande d'examen séparée est
adoptée je voudrais vous préciser avant
la suspension de séance ce que
l'adoption de cet amendement ferait
tomber comme autres amendements
pour que pour que les choses soient très
claires
ça ferait tomber à peu près une
soixantaine d'amendements
attendez
vous permettez
si vous voulez travailler sérieusement
président canner c'est le président
canner si vous voulez travailler
sérieusement faut quand même écouter ce
sinon vous allez vous demander après ce
qui va se passer donc l'adoption de
l'amendement 2132 ferait tomber les
amendements identiques de suppression
d'articles du 301 au 3790
ainsi que les amendements 44
430 43
3352 3136 et 3922
nous reprendrions à ce moment-là la
discussion à l'amendement 3308 est-ce
que j'ai été clair
madame de La Gontrie
monsieur le Président merci pour me
rappeler le règlement fondé sur le 46
bis l'article 46 bisit très clairement
les amendements doivent être examinés
par premièrement les amendements de
suppression et ensuite les autres
amendements donc vous venez énoncer et
je vous en remercie l'ordre d'examen des
amendements et vous avez annoncé
également que cela ferait tomber les
amendements qui pourtant sont des
amendements de suppression il y a donc à
mon sens une distorsion par rapport à
l'application
normale du règlement
Roger caoutchi n'a pas besoin de secouer
la tête en disant non je le connais
depuis tellement longtemps que je
connais sa façon de fonctionner
sachant que sachant que nous abordons
aussi la question délicate et je suggère
à la droite du Sénat d'être attentive à
ce point de la clarté de la sincérité du
débat parlementaire que nous allons
contester devant le Conseil
constitutionnel pourquoi
l'amendement vient des distribuer grâce
à la diligence de la science et nous
pouvons les en remercier car ils
n'étaient même pas dans l'allias
distribuée c'est à dire que nous n'avons
aucune visibilité sur le périmètre de la
discussion et nous pouvons nous étonner
qu'un amendement à la Linéa 4 de
l'article 9 fasse tomber des amendements
de suppression donc sur ce point là nous
nous opposons à cette demande de
réorganisation du débat et par ailleurs
monsieur le Président 5 minutes de
suspension c'est bien de bien vouloir
nous accorder une suspension puisque
vous seul pouvez en décider mais si nous
voulons que les travaux se fassent dans
des conditions correctes et n'atteignent
pas à l'excès la clarté la sincérité du
bas je pense que 30 minutes est plus
raisonnable
chers collègues chers collègues attendez
mes chers collègues par rapport je
réponds je réponds excusez-moi président
Laurent je réponds sur le règlement ce
que vous avez cité c'est sauf décision
du Sénat sur proposition de la
Commission saisie au fond et là il y a
une proposition de la Commission saisie
au fond et donc c'est une pratique
constante dans notre assemblée de
pratiquer de cette façon là donc il y a
pas il y a pas d'ambiguïté sur le il y a
pas d'ambiguïté sur le règlement je l'ai
revu il y a aucune ambiguïté sur ce
point là
écoutez moi je veux je veux bien
suspendre la séance pour 10 minutes
compte tenu du sujet
donc je suis sport la séance pour 10
minutes la séance est suspendue
la séance est reprise
président Gontard
merci monsieur le Président rappelle au
règlement sur l'article 44 bis sur la
sincérité des débats et puis je voulais
quand même vous rappeler que j'ai fait
un rappel réglement que je voulais
montrer clairement avant la suspension
de séance et que vous ne l'avez pas
autorisé alors que c'est de droit donc
ça c'est une ça c'est une une première
chose mais quand même sur ce qui est en
train de se passer ce qui est en train
de se passer ici avec cette amendement
qui du coup a priori va va supprimer un
certain nombre de nos amendements déjà
moi j'aimerais savoir et avoir une
explication très claire et très précise
de la part de la Commission sur en quoi
cet amendement va faire tomber
l'ensemble de nos amendements qui sont
qui sont derrière et j'aimerais avoir
vraiment des expressions très précises
parce que là on est vraiment sur un une
problématique constitutionnelle donc un
moment donné je pense qu'il faut
remettre un petit peu de sérieux sur ce
qu'on est en train de faire parce que
depuis deux jours c'est quand même un
petit peu du grand n'importe quoi lié à
vos actions et est-ce que vous êtes en
train de faire d'accord donc nous on a
déposé des amendements on a un certain
nombre on a un certain nombre
d'amendement sur le fond et là on n'est
pas en train de parler de n'importe quoi
on est en train de parler des risques
professionnels donc c'est quand même pas
n'importe quoi sur ce texte et là
et ben vous me vous me donnerez vous me
donnerez madame prima le nombre de
risques professionnels qu'il existe
d'accord et là vous verrez que
effectivement il peut y avoir bien plus
que 60 amendements sur la question de
ces risques professionnels donc à un
moment donné quand on veut travailler un
texte on travaille au fond on ne
travaille pas d'accord et ben nous on a
décidé de le travailler au fond donc
vous vous faites comme vous voulez mais
en tout cas la manière la manière dont
on se passe les débats actuellement ne
sont absolument pas sérieux de son
absolument pas sincères donc moi je veux
de rêver avoir des réponses très claires
et très précises sur Pourquoi et comment
cet amendement fait tomber l'ensemble
des nôtres des de des amendements qu'on
a pu déposer et puis franchement un
moment donné de revenir sur un peu de
sérénité on a déposé des amendements et
je vais vous je vais vous le redire je
vais vous je vais vous le redire 3000
amendements au début de ce texte vous
avez déposé je vous avais posé
merci pour votre appel de regroupement
je précise simplement que tout à l'heure
j'avais été saisi d'une suspension de
séance j'avais eu deux demandes de
suspension de séance et j'avais dit que
j'accordais la suspension de séance je
voulais simplement préciser des choses
avant la suspension c'est pour ça que je
n'ai pas donné la parole je n'ai pas
donné la parole ni au président kaner
d'ailleurs qui l'a demandé tout à
l'heure donc voilà c'est simplement pour
vous expliquer pourquoi ensuite pour la
clarté des débats j'ai précisé à
l'avance les amendements qui tomberaient
si l'abonnement la commission était
adoptée voilà je pense que je pense
qu'on est assez clair
voilà
monsieur qui est rouge
alors il s'avère monsieur le Président
et mes chers collègues alerte a priori
on s'est encore tous lire même si
j'imagine que en ce qui nous concerne
vous en doutez mais
c'est tout simple
vous devrez
si vous devriez vous calmer vous devriez
vous calmer ça va bien se passer tout va
bien se passer mais vous comprenez qu'on
a besoin d'une explication puisque
encore une fois les amendements de
suppression au nom de l'article 46 bis
de notre règlement sont considérés comme
des arguments qui sont prioritaires donc
la question elle est toute simple c'est
dans quelle mesure l'amendement qui a
été appelé en priorité par madame la
Présidente assez conséquences sur les
amendements de suppression ça me semble
pas du tout du tout une demande qui est
complètement indue et bien monsieur
carucci si vous avez la réponse j'en
suis content mais ça veut dire déjà
qu'on pourrait nous la donner c'est
aussi simple que ça et juste un petit
conseil c'est pas parce que vous êtes
juridiquement majoritaire que vous avez
politiquement raison
merci président Laurent
et monsieur le Président rappelle au
Règlement sur la base de l'article 46
bis
donc la Commission et la droite
sénatoriale viennent de déclencher la
énième
manœuvre procédurières depuis mardi soir
je tiens à faire remarquer que cette
fois-ci vous le déclenchez sur un
article majeur du projet de loi
l'article l'article l'article sur lequel
l'ensemble des organisations syndicales
insistent le plus depuis le début avec
l'article 7 donc ça n'est pas un article
mineur c'est un article majeur du projet
de loi et vous déclenchez une procédure
qui vise à faire tomber sur cet article
des dizaines et des dizaines
d'amendements alors que nous discutons
d'une question absolument essentielle
pour l'intérêt des travailleurs
et pour la vie de ces travailleurs
vous faites un appel à priorité en
désorganisant les débats bien sûr c'est
un droit de la commission mais je ferai
remarquer avec tout le respect que je
dois au service de la séance qui mène un
travail remarquable depuis le début que
si je puis dire ils ont eux-mêmes du mal
à suivre et à nous distribuer en temps
utile parce que vous cachez les
procédures que vous allez déclencher ce
qui empêche les services de la séance de
préparer correctement les dossiers et
d'informer correctement les
parlementaires pour pouvoir travailler
donc il y a effectivement de
l'insenséité dans la manière dont vous
organisez les débats
et vous les désorganiser volontairement
pour nuire à la qualité de nos débats et
enfin je voudrais dire que pour insister
sur ce qu'a dit ma collègue Marie-Pierre
delagonerie qu'il y a un sérieux
problème à faire effectivement tomber
tous les amendements de suppression ce
qui empêche le débat sur arctique avant
d'entrer dans le débat sur amendement et
par ailleurs comme ça vient aussi d'être
dit vous ne justifiez pas à aucun moment
puisqu'il n'y a eu aucune réunion de la
commission vous ne justifiez
tel amendement tombe merci merci chers
collègues il y a deux minutes pour
s'exprimer chacun a le droit de
s'exprimer pendant deux minutes ce qui
est bien donc monsieur Ferro
merci monsieur le Président pour un
rappel au règlement rappelons-le quand
même dans l'article 44 bis le
gouvernement et les sénateurs ont le
droit de présenter des amendements et
des sous amendements au texte soumis à
discussion devant le Sénat les
amendements sont recevables s'il
s'appliquent effectivement au texte
qu'il vise et s'ils ont un lien même
indirect avec le texte en discussion sur
les amendements qui de suppression nous
sommes vraiment exactement dans la
lettre et dans l'esprit de cet article
44 bis nous avons maintenant qu'il a été
distribué vu l'amendement proposé par la
Commission des affaires sociales
amendement qui en lui-même n'a
d'ailleurs enfin d'ailleurs beaucoup
d'intérêt mais qui est quand même à la
fois très bref
remplacer après la référence insérez les
mots et haut à du 2
et ensuite à la Linéa 7 au 1 au premier
paragraphe par les mots au premier
paragraphe et au has du deuxième
paragraphe est-ce que l'amendement de la
commission
change l'esprit de l'article 9 de du
projet de loi est-ce que dans l'esprit
il fait tomber les amendements de
suppression qui sont des objets pour
débattre vraiment de l'article 9 à
l'évidence non d'ailleurs je vois
l'empressement qui a été mis pour dire
cet amendement fait tomber 60 ou 70
amendements notamment de suppression
comme si c'était le but unique de
l'amendement présenté par la commission
des affaires sociales ça n'est pas cela
l'esprit de nos discussions
parlementaires l'amendement de la
commission s'il est mis en priorité
c'est pour clarifier notre débat ça ne
peut pas être dans le seul but de faire
tomber des amendements de suppression
donc je pense qu'il faut revoir l'ordre
de discussion de nos amendements merci
Monsieur Brouillet
merci monsieur le Président titre de
l'article 46 bis je voudrais reprendre
l'argumentaire qui vient d'être exposé
par mon collègue Ferro sur la question
des amendements de suppression je
voudrais ajouter que la qualité d'une
démocratie se lit toujours au traitement
qui est infligé au minorités et je pense
que la Commission sonnerait à expliquer
de façon détaillée les motifs de ce
changement de priorité nous traitons
d'un sujet qui va parler de l'usure
professionnelle et de la pénibilité ça
concerne des centaines de milliers de
nos concitoyens et franchement je pense
que nos débats sur cet article pourrait
relever d'une qualité plus grande que
celle qui est annoncée par cette
procédure merci
[Applaudissements]
oui rappelle le règlement article 46 bis
nous contestons l'organisation de
l'examen du début de cet article 9 nous
contestons la priorité demandée pour
l'amendement de Monsieur Savary en effet
le principe de disjonction des
amendements de suppression et reconnus
par le Sénat les amendements de
suppression sont toujours discutés en
amont et séparément des autres
amendements car ce sont justement des
discussions qui sont séparées et puisque
nous l'avons dit à plusieurs reprises il
a été extrêmement difficile pour nous de
nous retrouver dans le Méli-Mélo qui a
suivi la demande de priorité et ne dites
pas que c'était facile parce que nous
comme tout le monde ici nous avons
travaillé à des amendements à étudier le
texte est vraiment il a fallu je veux
remercier le président de séance qui a
accepté la suspension de séance pour
courner un petitrénité et un peu de
moments pour voir où on en était parce
que mes chers collègues heureusement
qu'il préside et qu'il n'a pas écouté
les rumeurs de certains bancs parce que
sinon on aurait même pas suspendu la
séance alors que plusieurs des collègues
étaient présents dans la salle n'avaient
même pas l'amendement réécrit c'est la
moindre de la démocratie la deuxième
chose dont que je veux dire c'est
puisque
vous la commission juge que il faut il y
a des examens il y a des amendements qui
tombent et qu'on vous a demandé à
plusieurs reprises des explications sur
les raisons pour lesquelles ces
amendements tombaient parce que ça
n'était absolument ni limpide ni logique
en tant que membre de la de la
commission des affaires sociales je
demande que la commission des affaires
sociales se réunissent pour étudier les
raisons qui font tomber les amendements
merci
même ma présidente
bien évidemment nous aurions réuni la
commission si l'abonnement avait été
réécrit mais il n'est pas réécrit c'est
exactement le même que celui que la
Commission examiné donc cet amendement a
été vu en commission
merci monsieur
un rappel aussi au règlement là il y a
un aveu
là il y a un aveu si c'est exactement le
même
ça a pas commencé la parole est à
Monsieur
si ça pas été si c'est exactement le
même
mais vous savez très bien que dans
l'organisation des débats vous auriez pu
le nicher à cet endroit si maintenant
vous le faites en disant que ça fait
tomber les autres c'est parce que vous
voulez écourter nos débats et vous
voulez empêcher qu'on défend nos
arguments
je veux avertir de quelque chose c'est
que je m'adresse à mes collègues de la
droite
vous êtes plus stributaire même que nous
de la fonction
que remplit cette chambre parce que vous
la dirigez
vous êtes en train de faire quelque
chose que vous n'avez pas osé faire
pendant tous les mandats où vous avez
été majoritaire ici pourquoi parce que
vous savez que quand on est responsable
d'une chambre parlementaire on la
défense or vous vous êtes mis dans une
seringue qui est la suivante
quand on a fait le débat sur les
retraites en 2010 alors que vous étiez
au gouvernement vous n'avez jamais
utilisé ces procédures là parce que on a
été au terme et au terme il y a toujours
un vote vous voulez le vote si on va au
terme il y aura un vote donc vous vous
êtes mis là dans une seringue qui est
celle que le gouvernement a voulu en
mettant l'article 47 1 de la
Constitution il a donné un délai et vous
au lieu de contester cela vous vous
cadrez dans le délai dès 50 jours et
vous voulez absolument qu'on vote avant
Dimanche soir
vous avez accepté de soumettre le Sénat
à la volonté de l'exécutif merci chers
collègues
la parlotte président rénale
président rénal vous aviez demandé la
parole non non
sur le même fondement
c'est quand même assez extraordinaire
du 46 sec etc ça a été dit déjà 46 10
monsieur le vice-président
soyez raisonnable bon
soyez raisonnable ça a bien se passer
non je dis pas ça allez je veux pas être
désagréable c'est pas c'est pas le sujet
non cette question
cette manœuvre que vous menez voir etc
je vous signale simplement un seul mot
il y a 70 amendements qui vont tomber ça
aurait fait 70 prise de parole sur le
sujet qui nous intéresse aujourd'hui on
va le remplacer par 70 règles
rappels du règlement c'est intelligent
et cette droite alors cette intelligent
moi j'aimerais plutôt qu'on enlève ça et
qu'on travaille au fond deuxième voilà
donc soyons quand même soyons quand même
sérieux sur les méthodes celles que vous
employez ne sont pas des méthodes
sérieuses et il faut vraiment revenir à
plus de calme et à traiter le sujet
d'autre part je vous rappelle et ça
c'est on peut le retrouver facilement
dans ce qu'on a dit c'est que
d'amendement en amendement vous nous
indiquez que les amendements importants
sur lesquels il faut consacrer du temps
c'est le 7 le 8 le 9 je reprends les
propos du rapporteur 8 9 10 qui sont les
sujets majeurs et dès qu'on y arrive
vous dites en couple et bien ça c'est
pas possible
alors
je précise simplement que après les
amendements qui tomberaient il en
restera 140 donc il restera quand même
140 prises de parole il faut quand même
il faut quand même dire les choses pour
que les débats soient claires monsieur
dessus monsieur dessus
oui rappelle le règlement sur le 44 bis
s'il vous plaît ce que je peux au moins
m'exprimer
sur mon rappel au règlement on est dans
un texte déjà contraint sur le 47,1
c'est le péché originel le PLFSS
rectificatif le gouvernement vous a
suivi il a utilisé le même véhicule
législatif que vous utilisez pour votre
projet de réforme des retraites chaque
année
c'est le péché originel vous avez
l'article 42 qui a déjà bien contraint
les débats qui nous ont empêché d'avoir
des explications de vote diverses vous
avez encore l'article 38 que vous pouvez
activer quand vous voulez mais vous avez
décidé d'activer encore autre chose la
réécriture et là je vais pas vous faire
un jour à relire comme la fève mon
collègue Ferro
l'amendement qu'on va le voir du
réécouter en priorité mais c'est quand
même assez anecdotique sur cet
amendement je pense que tous nos
amendements de suppression seraient
toujours de la même valeur puisqu'on
veut toujours supprimer cet article vous
engendre vous n'en changez pas la portée
on veut toujours le supprimer malgré ce
que vous rajoutez avec des détails
rédactionnels donc on voudrait toujours
pouvoir discuter de nos amendements de
suppression mais moi je pense qu'en plus
vous fragilisez le texte du Gouvernement
vous fragilisez le texte en heurtant le
droit d'amendement des parlementaires
comme vous le faites vous nous
fragilisez vous-même le texte que vous
portez et c'est extrêmement dangereux la
réalité c'est que vous êtes en train
d'inventer le 49-3 sénatorial pour accès
pour accélérer les débats en permanence
vous voulez faire bosser les Français
deux ans de plus mais vous n'êtes même
pas capable de vouloir bosser ce weekend
c'est ça la réalité si vous voulez pas
bosser ce week-end et donc vous
accélérez les débats c'est ça la
solution
merci chers collègues madame Brulin
merci monsieur le Président mon rappel
au règlement se font également sur
l'article 44 bis
régulièrement priorité et donner à des
amendements dans nos débats et quand
cette priorité est donnée elle est au
titre de la clarté et de la cohérence de
nos débats raison pour laquelle 9 fois
sur 10 que dis-je 9,9 fois sur 10 cette
priorité fait consensus or là quelle
cohérence y a-t-il à mettre en priorité
un amendement dont je ne déni ni
l'intérêt ni la légitimité un amendement
qui vise à inclure les agents chimiques
dans le fond
dont j'oublie le nom dans le fond de
prévention de l'usure professionnelle
qu'y a-t-il comme cohérence à mettre
donc c'est amendement en priorité par
rapport à des amendements qui par
exemple proposent
d'instruire la différence qui existe
entre l'usure qui est une
caractéristique individuelle avec avec
la pénibilité qui est la caractéristique
d'un métier quelle cohérence y a-t-il à
mettre cet amendement priorité sur des
amendements qui proposent d'associer les
partenaires sociaux à la définition des
missions de ce fond il me semble que
dans le climat actuel du pays associé
les partenaires sociaux ne seraient pas
du luxe quelle cohérence y a-t-il à ce
que cette priorité fasse tomber
l'amendement de notre collègue canevé
par exemple qui prévoit de laisser la
main à la branche ATMP et donc également
aux partenaires sociaux pour le
fonctionnement de ce fond il n'y en a
aucune et la seule vient d'être à
nouveau avouée c'est de faire tomber le
maximum d'amendement mes chers collègues
nous ne sommes là ni pour faire du
chiffre ni de la comptabilité et notre
légitimité n'est pas indexée sur le
nombre d'amendements qui tombent elle
est sur l'intérêt monsieur le rapporteur
Savary vous nous dites depuis le début
que vous souhaitez débattre de l'article
9 des bateaux -en merci chers collègues
monsieur Houlgate
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
mini mes chers collègues toujours sur la
base de l'article 44 bis je ne suis pas
juriste donc j'ai besoin de comprendre
vous m'excuserez mais ce que je sais
c'est que dans les débats juridiques il
y a toujours deux aspects il y a d'un
côté ce que l'on appelle le fond et de
l'autre côté la forme et là j'ai
l'impression qu'on est sur des artifices
de forme qu'on pourrait qualifier un peu
de tapis vert même si nos fauteuils sont
rouges mais néanmoins nous sommes un peu
dans le tapis vert de l'argument de
forme ce que j'ai besoin de comprendre
c'est tout simplement en quoi le fait
d'exhumer parce qu'il s'agit bien
d'exhumer de la colonne
l'amendement 2132 en quoi fait-il et
c'est ce qu'a dit Madame Brulin en quoi
fait-il comment dirais-je tomber tous
les autres amendements alors on pourrait
moi qui essaie de réfléchir de façon un
peu logique mais en disant ben à partir
du moment où on discute
commandement du texte un peu au fond
cette fois-ci ils n'ont pas sur la forme
à partir du moment où on discute d'un
amendement au fond et bien si on discute
d'un amendement au fond c'est que
implicitement on reconnaît que cet
article existe toujours et qu'il n'a pas
été supprimé qu'à partir de ce moment il
ne peut plus l'être alors est-ce que
c'est est-ce que mon raisonnement est
logique et ce qu'il est fondé mais nous
avons tous ici dans l'hémicycle besoin
de comprendre en quoi le fait d'exhumer
cette amendement 2132 fait tomber tous
ceux que vous avez mentionné monsieur le
Président merci chers collègues monsieur
Dantec
oui merci monsieur le Président il
s'agit donc bien évidemment d'un rappel
aux règlements je crois que le principe
d'un amendement qui fait tomber les
autres amendements c'est qu'il
restructure le débat nous sommes sur un
débat absolument essentiel
44 bis mais vous avez suivi
44 bis écoutez 44 vis il y avait un
troisième fois que je le dis
il est très clair que votre amendement
traite la question de l'usure
professionnelle par remplacer les mots
O1 par les mots au 1 et au 2 c'est pas
sérieux c'est pas sérieux effectivement
vous avez beaucoup d'amendements de
suppression parce que il nous semble que
le dispositif proposé ne répond en rien
aux questions posées donc tous les
amendements qui ont été déposés c'est
pour qu'on ait le débat sur cette
question centrale à partir du moment où
on a effectivement un âge de la retraite
repoussée de l'usure professionnelle on
aurait pu avoir des débats extrêmement
intéressants monsieur le ministre par
exemple aurait pu nous dire j'ai bien
entendu les propos de Monsieur Patriat
je lance dès aujourd'hui une filière
industrielle de production
d'exosquelette dont on va effectivement
équiper la quasi-totalité des
travailleurs français et ça va créer de
l'emploi et on a déjà des de la
recherche des fonds de développer ça
aurait permis un débat très structuré
sur cette question de la généralisation
des exosquelettes pour limiter l'usure
au travail mais ce débat nous ne
l'aurons pas et ça n'est pas possible ça
n'est pas possible de de passer un
article aussi important par simplement
un changement d'alinéa les Français nous
regardent on est sur des textes
essentiels pour leur avenir nous sommes
nous avons joué cet après-midi cet
après-midi nous avons fait l'inverse
nous sommes allés au bout nous avons
voté ensemble un amendement il faut
garder la même logique vous changez ce
soir de logique les Français vous
regardent ils sont extrêmement déçus
monsieur benaroche
bonsoir monsieur le Président bonsoir
chers collègues alors sur la base du 44
vis en fait je crois que les choses
doivent être clair à un moment donné on
essaye de vous faire dire les raisons de
l'utilisation des procédures que vous
utilisez que vous employez et que vous
avez continué à employer ce soir en fait
la raison est simple je l'ai entendu
dire sur sur les bords par un certain
nombre de mes collègues faites vous avez
que de volonté ce n'est pas de débattre
sur ce texte pour essayer de l'améliorer
ou d'essayer effectivement de faire
passer les messages qui permettraient à
nos interlocuteurs citoyens et syndicats
d'accepter à certains groupes de mesures
et de pouvoir peser sur un certain
nombre d’autres c'est simplement que
vous ne voulez pas que nous en
débattions et que vous souhaitiez et que
vous souhaitez d'une manière très claire
vous pouvez vous exprimer en prenant la
parole cher ami et que vous souhaitez
donc d'une manière très claire que ce
texte soit voté
qu'une discussion des lieux sur les
paragraphes sur les points sur les
articles les plus importants qui ont été
listés par le par le rapporteur lui-même
donc je suis désolé je n'entends pas
quand vous parlez fort de loin donc vous
pouvez parler longtemps je n'entends pas
voilà donc d'une manière très claire
aujourd'hui vous avez une stratégie la
stratégie que vous déployez vous essayez
de la déployer en plus ça a été dit ici
d'une manière cachée qui nuit donc à la
sincérité des débats c'est à dire vous
opposer à certains nobles de de
d'amendement qui arrive de telle façon à
empêcher le débat en supprimant des sous
amendements et en plus vous le faites
d'une manière telle que vous ne
l'argumentez même pas donc au moins
argumentez le c'est ce que nous
demandons expliquez-nous pourquoi
certains nobles de d'amendements en fait
ne peuvent plus être discutés en raison
de ce nouvel amendement qui a été déposé
par la commission nous ne le comprenons
pas vous pouvez nous l'expliquer nous ne
comprenons votre tactique vous ne
comprenez pas les moyens que vous
utilisez et excus ez-moi de vous le dire
si nous ne le comprenons pas je pense
que beaucoup qui nous écoutent qui nous
entendent pas non plus monsieur Richard
monsieur le Président puisque nous
discutons règlement et procédure
législatives
je crois que
l'analyse de l'article 40 l'analyse de
l'article 44 bis si Monsieur Kerrouche
tolère que je puisse m'exprimer
d'accord mais si nous nous interrompons
aussi
activement à chaque fois quelqu'un
prononce une syllabe ça ne ressemble
plus monsieur kerouche à un débat
démocratique acceptez-vous de vous taire
je reprends
il est vous si vous acceptez
d'écouter un raisonnement quelques
instants lorsque nous avons une
discussion commune nous y sommes tous
habitués
sont mises en discussion commune les
amendements qui portent sur les mêmes
éléments du texte et dont l'adoption
serait contradictoire c'est à dire que
lorsque plusieurs amendements portent
sur le même point ils sont mis en
discussion comme une parce que
l'adoption de l'un entraînerait la perte
de sens des autres
c'est exactement la même chose et c'est
une question de logique monsieur
Houlgate a dit très justement le droit
est une logique et donc si l'amendement
qui a été mis en avant de la discussion
commune est adoptée ça veut dire que en
l'adoptant le Sénat adopte une
disposition de l'article et par
conséquent écarte les amendements de
suppression c'est aussi simple que ça et
vous le pratiquez dans tous les débats
législatifs donc ça me paraît pas être
une grande découverte
et chers collègues madame Lubin
et en vertu de l'article 46
bis les amendements que que vous enlevez
correspondent tout à fait à l'esprit de
l'article à l'esprit du texte donc nous
ne comprenons pas effectivement pourquoi
ils sont enlevés et nous avions
permettez-moi de vous rappeler quand
même que l'une des premières actions que
vous avez faites en 2017 que le
gouvernement a fait en 2017 c'est
d'enlever les critères de pénibilité que
nous avions introduit dans la loi donc
permettez nous quand même de manquer un
petit peu de confiance et de considérer
que nous devons travailler cet
amendement ce cet article à fond pour
être assuré que les travailleurs
retrouveront des protections qu'ils ont
perdu grâce si je puis dire à vos
actions précédentes et après avoir voté
un allongement de la durée de travail
après avoir voté
certes des des dispositifs carrières
longues mais qui rallongent quand même
la durée de travail les salariés
attendent de nous que nous soyons
extrêmement convaincants sur cet article
9 d'ailleurs j'ai souvent entendu le
rapporteur ça varie au cours des débats
lorsque vous vous inquiétez de savoir si
nous allions arriver à un moment à
l'article 7 s'inquiéter de savoir si
nous arrivions à l'article 9 et bien
l'article 9 nous y sommes et nous
voulons débattre de tout parce que c'est
salariés à qui vous allez demander de
travailler deux ans de plus et notamment
en carrière longue c'est-à-dire ceux qui
travaillent déjà depuis longtemps ont le
droit de d'être protégé et ce sont
souvent ceux qui sont le moins protégés
donc nous nous demandons à revoir tous
nos tous nos amendements afin de
travailler sur cet article le du mieux
possible et sur les meilleurs fondements
sur la base de 44 bis et de la sincérité
de la clarté des débats
moi j'aimerais mettre à jour
l'enjeu de ne pas nous permettre de dire
pourquoi nous voulons supprimer
l'article quand on dit qu'on veut
supprimer un article on dit que en fin
de compte on demande à prendre du champ
et sur ce thème sur le sujet de la
pénibilité la méditabilité en lien avec
le fait qu'il va falloir travailler deux
ans de plus on regarde toutes les
applications de cela et ça nous permet
effectivement de dire si les mesures que
vous allez proposer dont la première
monsieur le rapporteur général que me
rapporteur qu'on peut tout à fait
soutenir sur sur les sur les chimiques
si le compte y est ce que quand on dit
on supprime un article on dit on va me
on va me prendre en compte le fait que
les mesures que vous nous proposez les
fameuses mesures d'accompagnement est-ce
que le compte y est par rapport à
l'ampleur du sujet de la pénibilité en
lien avec nous avons supplémentaires de
travail donc on nous empêchant de dire
pourquoi on veut supprimer l'article
tout en peut-être
validant certaines mesures vous nous
empêchez effectivement
de donner du sens à nos votes futurs je
voudrais quand même rappeler que nous
avons été frappés par 10% de nos amants
nos amendements ils recevables au titre
de l'article 44 90% au titre d'oeil y
avait pas de lien et pas de lien direct
ou indirects ce qui était vraiment faux
là on est de nouveau dans une vague où
on nous supprime encore des amendements
où on explique notre position je veux
dire en termes de clarté et de débats
vraiment le compte n'y est pas le compte
ce n'est pas sur l'article 9 nous
voulions vous dire pourquoi nous
n'allons pas pouvoir puisque en fin de
compte on peut discuter que des 140
amendements que vous gagnez nous laisser
à disputer
gues monsieur chanterelle
merci monsieur le Président c'est un
rappel réglement l'article 44 bis
également
alors chers collègues ce qui se passe
depuis quelques jours de au sein de
cette hémicycle il est quand même
particulièrement gravissime si on
remonte un peu l'histoire
vous avez commencé tous ces procédés
depuis les manifestations massives de
mardi depuis que vous avez vu que les
Françaises et les Français étaient
massivement mobilisés vous avez commencé
à pratiquer ces manœuvres pour accélérer
le texte pourquoi puisque plus nous
parlons du texte plus nous parlons du
fond plus ça vous dérange parce que nous
mettons en exergue l'injustice de ce
texte face à vous à tel point que plus
nous en parlons plus des personnes chez
vous se rétractent et retire leur vote
et vous savez que si nous continuons à
débattre il y aura de plus en plus de
personnes qui se rendront compte
justement au sein de cette hémicycle que
cette réforme est injuste que cette
effort est brutale
justement par rapport à cet article 9
qui est sans aucun doute aussi avec
l'article 7 que vous avez voté un des
plus injustes vous vous dites ah mais si
on débat du fond il y aura encore des
personnes qui vont se rétracter comme
celles qui seront rétractées à l'article
7 étant demain il est particulièrement
juste c'est sur la pénibilité justement
laisser les Français avoir le droit à se
débat laisser aux Français qui ont les
métiers les plus pénibles de pouvoir
justement qu'on débatte de ces choses là
ça ça serait l'honneur du Parlement et
actuellement vous foulez le Parlement
vous l'écraser avec vos mesures
si Monsieur blé
monsieur le Président mes chers
collègues mon intervention est un rappel
réglement sur la base non pas comme
l'essentiel de des intervenants
précédents sur la base d'article 44 bis
mais sur la base de l'article 46 bis que
dit-il dans son deuxième alinéa il dit
la chose suivante les amendements sont
mises au voie dans l'ordre ci-après les
amendements de suppression et ensuite
les autres amendements en commençant par
ceux qui s'écartent le plus du texte
proposé et dans l'ordre où il s'y oppose
s'y intercale ou s'y ajoute toutefois
lorsque le Sénat a adopté une priorité
ou une réserve dans les conditions
fixées à l'alinéa 6 de l'article 44
l'ordre de mise au voie est modifié en
conséquence
lorsqu'ils viennent en concurrence et
sauf décision contraire de la Conférence
des présidents ou décisions du Sénat sur
proposition de la Commission saisie au
fond les amendements font l'objet d'une
discussion commune à l'exception écoutez
bien à l'exception des amendements de
suppression et de rédaction globale de
l'article et donc nous contestons
absolument monsieur le Président
formellement le fait que par la décision
que vous nous proposiez il puisse y
avoir une disparition des amendements de
suppression qui doivent être examinés en
premier lieu et avant tout autre
merci Monsieur Cabanel
[Applaudissements]
monsieur Cabanel
au règlement vertu de l'article 44 bits
sur la clarté des débats cet article 9
portant sur la pénibilité est un article
très très important et c'est vrai que je
suis aussi surpris que par rapport donc
à la priorité beaucoup d'amendements
soit enlevé et je suis d'autant plus
surpris que j'aurais souhaité que la
majorité sénatoriale puisse expliquer
clairement donc à l'autre moitié
pourquoi effectivement ils avaient
choisi ce process
par contre
puisque la majorité sénatoriale ne le
dit pas et je le regrette moi je vais
essayer très humblement sans sans
polémique essayer de le dire
nous aussi on n'a pas beaucoup porté
d'avant de main et on va subir le fait
que un abandonnement soit supprimé mais
je pense que pour la sérénité des débats
il faut aussi reconnaître que la série
d'amendements
identique nombreux 55
me paraît un peu exagéré alors que il y
a d'autres amendements sur lesquels on
pourrait effectivement
pouvoir débattre sereinement donc moi ce
que je vous demande ce que ce que je
vous demande parce que je sais pas vous
mais moi j'ai un sentiment de honte de
vivre ce convida parce que on est en
dehors du débat alors qu'on y était
juste avant et c'était très intéressant
donc moi ce que je vous demande et on
vous l'a demandé déjà à plusieurs
reprises je pense que les uns et les
autres en tout cas ce qui nous concerne
nous le RDSE on veut aller jusqu'au bout
du débat pour voter oui ou non et on
travaillera jusqu'à minuit le dimanche
minuit s'il le faut méditer l'heure à
eux si oui ou non vous voulez aller au
bout du débat pour voter
merci chers collègues
madame meunier madame meunier
oui merci monsieur le Président comme
mon collègue je ne suis pas coutumière
de ce rappel règlement je pense que
c'est même la première fois que j'en
fais un depuis que je suis sénatrice
donc sur la base de l'article 44 bis
rappelle du règlement je ne comprends
pas et on est plusieurs ici à poser et à
reposer et la même question qu'est-ce
que cette affaire de disjonctions tout
d'un coup vient faire dans le débat
alors quel sens ça va donner sur
l'article 9 monsieur le rapporteur on
attend des réponses qui soient peut-être
moins formelle que ce que vous allez
nous dire mais plus sur le fond parce
que c'est le fond c'est le sens de
l'article 9 qui nous intéresse donc
voilà donc je pose la question comme mes
collègues l'ont déjà fait merci Monsieur
Osias
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mais mes chers collègues
j'interviens à mon tour sur la base de
l'article 46 bis pour aller en
complément de l'excellent argumentaire
de notre collègue et blé vous voulez
supprimer chers collègues les
amendements suppression je vous pose une
question de pure logique il y a pas de
politique il y a pas de règlement c'est
de la pure logique alors c'est une
question comment fait-on pour supprimer
des amendements de suppression d'un
article et une seule réponse c'est de
supprimer l'article voilà donc ce que je
vous propose c'est de supprimer
l'article 9 et on ira beaucoup plus vite
merci
Monsieur salmon
merci monsieur le Président c'est un
rappel au règlement également vertu de
l'article 44 bis
rendez-vous compte mes chers collègues
vous enjambez la question de la
pénibilité de l'usure au travail vous le
savez en ce moment les Français sont un
véritable questionnement face au sens du
travail face aux conditions de travail
cet article 9 était le moment adéquat le
moment pour débattre de ces sujets les
travailleuses de l'agroalimentaire les
tâches ronds du bâtiment ne semble pas
vous intéresser
c'est dommage vraiment j'avais quelque
part une autre image de votre rapport au
travail mais effectivement cela ne
semble pas vous intéresser
votre seul objectif c'est d'accélérer de
tronquer le débat
le bruit les travaux répétitifs le froid
l'eau chaud l'humidité les pressions de
tous ordres qu'elles soient physiques ou
psychiques ne vous intéresse pas
les débats ne me semblent pas
aujourd'hui du tout sincère
et je vous demande de vous de vous
reprendre parce que là on est en train
de d'opérer complètement un débat un
débat nécessaire un débat attendu par
les Françaises et les Français qui chers
collègues monsieur Chassin
merci merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur Miss mes chers collègues moi je
voulais revenir sur une loi qui est on
peut dire qui qui fait consensus c'est
quand même la loi Touraine Hollande
de
290 de 2014 qui va obliger qui oblige
mais en fait je pense que le président
Hollande l'a fait pour le bien de des
retraites qui oblige 43 ans de
cotisations et là cette loi ne change
pas elle était en 2035 elle est un petit
peu avancée en 2000 en 2027 donc les
personnes qui ont commencé à travailler
à 21 ans et bien pour prendre la
retraite après 43 ans elles auront 64
ans puisque il faut quand même éclairer
aussi le
nos citoyens donc en plus en plus j'ai
pas j'ai pas parlé beaucoup jusqu'à
maintenant monsieur le Président donc
en plus en plus il y a un relèvement de
l'âge donc ces deux données doivent
s'accompagner d'une meilleure prise en
cause de la pénibilité c'est le cas de
l'article 9 et oui absolument et donc il
faut y aller rapidement améliorant
amélioration de la C2P
valorisation des personnes exposées à la
pénibilité c'est dans l'article emploie
tant partiel c'est dans l'article font
de prévention c'est dans l'Arctique les
branches qui s'occuperont des métiers
pénibles négociations à établir et
l'exposition d'un salarié a des facteurs
de risque d'hommes des points au C2P
voilà pour la formation pour la
réduction de durée de travail pour le
départ en retraite anticipée voilà ce
que je voulais simplement dire et bien
sûr on aurait pu avoir une loi de
travail avec la concertation avec les
partenaires sociaux mais cet article
apporte des aménagements très
constructifs
qui pourront encore être améliorés avec
les partenaires sociaux
merci Madame à poursuppoli
oui merci monsieur le Président un
rappel au règlement donc
article 46 bis
ça vous fait rire monsieur Savary
ouais ouais madame la Présidente
je commence à causer et Monsieur ça
varie se retourne donc c'est bon allez
allez allez
madame la Présidente
madame la Présidente de la Commission
je pense que tout à l'heure vous n'avez
pas compris finalement la demande de ma
collègue Laurence Cohen elle vous
demande légitimement une réunion de la
commission des affaires sociales nos
amendements les plus de 70 que vous
venez de faire tomber ici
a été recevable par la commission madame
la Présidente vous êtes en train de vous
servir de tous les artifices possibles
pour nous empêcher de défendre des
amendements de suppression où nous
avions des arguments importants à
défendre sur les actions de prévention
finalement
si nous avions discuté des amendements
de suppression cela nous aurait pris
deux heures et demie et avec les
différents rappels au règlement qui sont
un droit des parlementaires nous en
sommes déjà à une heure de débat alors
réfléchis à ce que vous faites parce que
je pense que vous êtes pris à votre
propre jeu
d'accord merci monsieur Durand
oui merci monsieur le Président rappelle
au règlement en vertu de l'article 44
bis
je réitère les demandes d'explication
conformé un certain nombre d'orateurs
sur le choix de l'appel en priorité de
l'amendement présenté par le rapporteur
Savary
l'explication de la disjonction de cet
amendement et j'y ajoute une question
plus naïve sur un plan purement
arithmétique
la procédure a été enclenchée à 21h54
si on considère que l'ensemble des
auteurs d'amendements de suppression
n'étaient pas présents dans l'hémicycle
vous n'allez pas gagner une minute à
cette affaire et nous aurons passé plus
d'une heure une heure et demie à parler
de la forme sans parler du fond vous
pouvez nous adresser vous pouvez nous
adresser tous les reproches tous les
reproches mais celui qui dit ici que les
membres de ces trois groupes n'ont pas
travaillé au fond et n'avait pas à la
faveur des amendements de suppression
des questions fondamentales qui
intéressent les Français dans leur vie
quotidienne celui-là mais ne rend pas
justice au travail que nous avons fourni
par ailleurs s'il fallait que nous
expliquons aux Français en montrant en
produisant cet amendement que c'est pour
cette raison qu'on perd une heure à
parler de rien alors qu'on avait à
parler de tout ce qui les concerne
franchement je crois pas que ça honore
notre travail merci chers collègues
présidents
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre
je pense que tous les sénateurs qui sont
ici ont beaucoup d'heures de vol en
politique
la plupart en tout cas
et
objectivement je ne suis pas sûr qu'il y
ait beaucoup néanmoins de perdus de
l'année dans cette hémicycle mais par
contre il y a des arroseurs arrosés ça
j'en vois beaucoup sur le côté droit de
l'émission
Jérôme Durin vient de l'expliquer
si vous voulez nous brider en termes de
temps de parole nous avons le moyen oui
vous utilisez le 46 bis
c'est votre droit plus strict nous on
utilise notre droit au travers du rappel
le règlement je pense qu'il faut
s'arrêter il faut arrêter parlons du
fond ça fait plus d'une heure
effectivement qu'on ne parle pas du fond
une heure et demie donc si vous pensez
que nous allons plier le genou mettre
notre robe de bure et l'accord de coût
la réponse est non
la réponse est non donc est-ce qu'on
peut être un moment donné un peu
intelligent en se disant que nous nous
avons des choses à dire vous avez des
choses à dire et à défendre et utiliser
cet amendement intéressant mais qui
n'est quand même pas cardinal pour être
en premier vis-à-vis d'amendement de
suppression qui sont dans le 46 bis
reconnu comme des amendements essentiels
mes chers collègues de droite vous
faites fausse route donc
ressuscessez-vous et nous serons en
capacité de montrer aux Français que la
Haute Assemblée défend leurs intérêts
quel que soit les bandes de cette
hémicycle et Monsieur Fernique
monsieur Fernique
oui merci monsieur le Président chers
collègues donc sur la base de l'article
46 règlement et aussi de l'article 36
même si en principe on n'a pas le droit
de l'invoquer parce que c'est celui qui
parle des rappels au règlement bah
justement vous découvrez et nous
découvrons aussi on le dit le fait qu'il
n'y a pas de limite au rappel aux
règlements donc
tenter de raccourcir nos débats surtout
quand il porte sur des enjeux essentiels
de la réforme en ouvrant par la même les
vannes des débats de procédure pour
lesquels vous l'avez vu beaucoup d'entre
nous ont beaucoup de choses à dire je
crois qu'il est temps de mesurer les
avantages et les inconvénients chacun le
fait on vit une période un peu inédite
si je l'ai bien compris même si je suis
un peu récent dans la fonction
sénatoriale mais j'ai bien compris que
beaucoup ne disent qu'ils n'ont jamais
vu ça alors prenons compte prenons en
compte les uns et les autres l'image que
donne notre Sénat et avançons sur le
fond il y a encore un certain nombre
d'heures d'ici le moment où le carrosse
se transformera peut-être en citrouille
dimanche à minuit chers collègues
monsieur Fichet monsieur Fichet
oui merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
le Ministre en fait moi je pense que là
on exprime le fond de nos pensées c'est
la question de la pénibilité depuis le
début la pénibilité on accroche là
dessus d'abord le président de la
République a supprimé les quatre
critères les plus importants et puis
après avec l'allongement du de la
retraite de 62 à 64 en allonge pour les
personnes handicapées des personnes en
difficulté de 60 à 62 ans et ce soir à
travers l'article 9 on pouvait affronter
discuter de ces questions de pénibilité
et vous faites tomber carrément tous nos
amendements et ça à mon avis c'est très
révélateur de la pensée ou de la
perséoper perception que la vôtre du
travail alors en termes de
d'amendement
d'articles qui suppriment les autres
abonnements je connais l'article 40 on
nous le dit souvent attendez là vous
allez générer de nouvelles dépenses donc
on peut pas retenir vos amendements mais
pour le cas qui nous intéresse ce soir
il n'y a pas de nouvelles dépenses il y
a un débat de fond et donc je regrette
vraiment la situation dans laquelle on
est à un moment où je vous parle merci
si Monsieur Cardon
rappel au Règlement
sur l'article 42 bis écoutez chers
collègues je suis au moment où on
voulait parler de la pénibilité j'ai
l'impression que vous devenez pénible
c'est quand même dommage
alors j'ai bien compris que aujourd'hui
ça y est c'est un grand soir pour vous
vous êtes totalement converti au
macronisme
pourquoi
si je reprends la citation de Macron moi
je n'adore pas le mot de pénibilité
parce que ça donne le sentiment que le
travail c'est pénible et oui octobre
2019 effectivement on vous propose
justement débattre sur les amendements
sur la pénibilité vous ne voulez pas
c'est voilà mais si on en croit la suite
quand même des débats et je suis assez
inquiet sur votre comportement en
réalité
c'est que vous jouez au bento en fait là
vous faites vous essayez de changer les
ordres changer les règles enfin déjà
c'est déjà que la réforme des retraites
elle est compliquée pour les Français
vous vous en rajoutez
donc au bout d'un moment je sais pas si
c'est vous et puis je propose peut-être
à la prison de la Commission de retirer
cet amendement en fait pour qu'on
revienne à la case départ de ce
macropolis justement
chers collègues donc sur cet article 9
j'ai deux prises de parole madame ponce
prise de parole vous avez demandé la
prise de parole sur l'article pour ces
Monges
à moins que vous ayez pu intervenir
oh même si il est très tard
merci monsieur le président
l'article propose la création de fonds
d'investissement dans la prévention de
l'usure professionnelle
usure professionnelle plutôt que
pénibilité au travail nous notons les
mots du pouvoir
autant que le pouvoir des mots pourtant
usure et pénibilité sont intrinsèquement
corrélés à des mots nous répondrons donc
par des chiffres les 8 et demi les
données scientifiques disponibles
permettent d'estimer que 8 et demi des
cancers sont d'origine professionnelle
43% selon la chercheuse Dominique Méda
pour plus de 43% des Français leur
emploi implique de déplacer des charges
lourdes
57% pour 57% des Français leur travail
implique des positions douloureuses ou
fatigantes 2 millions c'est le nombre de
salariés qui selon la dernière enquête
surveillance médicale des expositions
des salariés aux risques professionnels
sont exposés à au moins un cancérogènes
11 ans selon l'Insee on faisant des
cartes d'espérance de vie sans
incapacité sépare pour les hommes les
ouvriers des cadres comme dans une moine
mesure chez les femmes à quand Monsieur
le Ministre une réforme des retraites
dont l'espérance de vie en bonne santé
sera le paramètre central
719 morts depuis 2017 le nombre de morts
au travail de nouveaux grimper passant à
719 morts je rappelle que la
ces européenne donne comme objectif pour
2030 zéro mort au travail vous avez du
travail
ainsi ne devrait-on parler ne devrait-on
pas parler de pénibilité lorsque nous
parlons d'usure ce sont les corps qui
s'usent par le travail ce qui renvoie à
une réalité individuelle constatée donc
curative alors que quand on parle de
pénibilité ce sont les métiers qui sont
pénibles d'où une présomption une
présomption d'usure et une notion
préventive merci à tous la parole à
Madame Ferret
et après
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues ce soir
j'ai honte j'ai honte parce qu'avec
votre décision vous dites aux Français
que vous empêchez le débat sur un sujet
essentiel de cette réforme que la
pénibilité que des milliers de salariés
vivent au quotidien alors oui j'ai honte
que le Sénat soit dans cette situation
et que nous ne puissions en parler pour
autant vous n'allez pas m'empêcher de
parler et de dire tout ce que j'avais
prévu d'évoquer dans le cadre de cette
intervention sur article
le droit à la retraite est une grande
conquête sociale et on ne peut pas
parler de retraite sans parler du
travail et des conditions de travail or
dans votre projet de réforme monsieur le
ministre la question de pénibilité au
travail est posée de manière pour le
moins problématique que vous le vouliez
ou non certains métiers sont dangereux
pénibles mais le gouvernement préfèrent
parler d'usure professionnelle que de
pénibilité mais ce n'est pas la même
chose la pénibilité porte sur le travail
et sur ces conditions donc sur une
responsabilité collective alors que lui
j'en professionnel porte sur les corps
des travailleurs donc sur une
responsabilité individuelle nous n'avons
pas les mêmes valeurs
il est toujours utile de rappeler que
lors du premier quinquennat d'Emmanuel
Macron en 2017 c'était à peine hier
l'exécutif a supprimé par ordonnance 4
critères de pénibilité sur 10 introduits
en 2015 le port de charge lourdes les
postures pénibles les vibrations
mécaniques comme celle des marsupiettes
et l'exposition au risque chimique qui
n'ouvrent donc plus la possibilité de
partir tôt nous avions proposé un
amendement pour réintroduire ce critère
dans le compte professionnel de
prévention mais là encore dans la mesure
où le véhicule législatif choisi qu'un
projet de loi de financement
rectificatif de la sécurité sociale et
bien on ne nous permet pas de débattre
de ces vrais enjeux comme dans d'autres
et cet amendement a été déclaré
irrecevable voilà comment nous sommes
empêchés dans le débat en l'état avec
votre réforme et de constater que vous
demandez à des Français déjà exposés de
travailler encore et toujours
donc nous passons maintenant à
l'amendement qui a été appelé en
priorité ah pardon pas dans Madame pour
ce poli j'avais pas vu j'avais pas vu
pardon
un grand auteur un jour convient un
journaliste au fur et à mesure que
l'épreuve de l'usine avance il faut
puiser au plus profond de ses ressources
pour pouvoir continuer à tenir et on se
raccroche à tout ce qui peut nous faire
tenir non chers collègues il ne s'agit
ni d'un auteur du XIXe siècle ni du 20e
siècle mais d'un contemporain qui décrit
le travail dans un abattoir
d'aujourd'hui il s'agit des mots du
défunt écrivain Joseph ponctu auteur du
livre à la ligne lors d'une interview
sur France culture donnée il y a de ça
trois ans lors de l'examen de cette
réforme que ce soit l'Assemblée
nationale ou ici au Sénat vous n'avez de
16 d'essayer de segmenter les hommes et
les femmes de ce pays entre les supposés
privilégiés des régimes spéciaux et les
autres le droit des nouveaux entrants et
les autres bénéficiant de la clause du
grand-père et ce constat s'applique
jusqu'à vos choix sémantique on ne doit
pas dire ouvrier mais opérateur votre
production on dit plus chaîne mes lignes
on doit surtout plus évoquer le mode
pénibilité lorsque l'on parle du travail
cette euphémisme
euphémisation des termes que l'on
constate depuis des années que je
constate depuis nos débats de vendredi
dernier et que je déplore que ce soit
dans les rares propos de la droite et
dans les votes monsieur le ministre sont
symptomatique de votre déconnexion de la
dure réalité du travail d'une grande
partie des travailleurs de ce pays voire
même et je le risquerais à le dire
traduit à certains mépris de classe
c'est dur c'est même très dur de
travailler à l'usine comme en témoigne
le surcoût en rente d'invalidité de 1,8
milliards d'euros par an en cas de
relèvement de deux ans de l'âge de
départ à la retraite mais face à cela
vous comptez ne doté que de 250 millions
d'euros par an votre fond jusqu'en 2027
en résumé alors même que la pénibilité
au travail devrait être un sujet central
de ce projet de loi le gouvernement n'y
consacre qu'un article qui est largement
insuffisante merci chers collègues
je rappelle que avec la Conférence des
Présidents il a été décidé qu'il n'y
avait que une prise de parole par groupe
c'est pour ça que je ne donne pas de
plus de prise de parole messieurs
mesdames qu'il a réclamé alors je donne
la parole à la Commission pour la
présentation de l'amendement 2132 de la
commission qui a été appelé en priorité
merci monsieur le Président je
m'impatientais d'avoir la parole parce
que je l'ai demandé aussi depuis un
moment mais je n'ai pas eu droit
monsieur le rapporteur content d'avoir
le droit parce que vous avez à travers
vos propos
demandez des explications aux rapporteur
et j'attends impatiemment de vous les
donner que voulez-vous
moi dans la vie on m'a appris qu'on
récoltait ce qu'on avait semé
vous avez récolté vous récoltez ce que
vous avez semé la semaine dernière
vous avez
vous n'avez pas tenu vos engagements et
quand on tient pas les engagements
demandez à vos présidents de groupe ils
savent bien de quoi je parle
demandez-leur ne criez pas comme ça
tenez-vous engagements il y a des
accords qui permettent effectivement de
faire de travailler dans des bonnes
conditions
avec des fixations de dates pour
répondre aux exigences de certains qui
sont tout à fait compréhensibles mais en
contrepartie en contrepartie il était
bien question que l'on puisse débattre
du texte pour aller jusqu'au bout du
texte
d'accord et vous savez ma préoccupation
par rapport à ces problèmes de
pénibilité et quand je vois tous ces
débats tous ces sous amendements quand
je vois tous ces amendements de
suppression sur un texte aussi important
sur la pénibilité j'ai demandé à madame
la Présidente de présenter cet
amendement en priorité pourquoi
parce que ça a été rappelé les agents
chimiques ne sont pas pris en compte
ni dans le C2P ni dans les propositions
qui sont faites actuellement à travers
un fonds d'investissement et c'est une
divergence que nous avons avec le
gouvernement et c'est pour ça que je
veux qu'on en discute parce que je veux
pas qu'il sorte un texte qui soit pas
voté parce qu'il y a eu obstruction et
on n'est pas apporté des améliorations
par rapport à la prise en compte de la
pénibilité alors entrons maintenant au
cœur du sujet
la Commission a souhaité effectivement à
la demande des syndicats
qu'on reprenne des mesures de prévention
sur les agents chimiques pourquoi parce
que actuellement ils sont traités
complètement différemment parce qu'on
pense à quoi aux agents chimiques qui
sont vendus ces produits qui sont
ensuite distribués on ne pense pas à
tous ces travailleurs qui sont exposés à
travers la fumée à travers les
poussières et qui sont des agents
chimiques et qui méritent d'être pris en
compte et plutôt avec des actions de
prévention que des actions de réparation
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous nous
a paru indispensable à la commission
d'inscrire cette disposition dès à
présent ouvrant droit au fond
d'investissement qui va être créé il est
réservé son investissement que pour les
troubles ergonomiques et bien sûr il y a
une dissociation dans la pénibilité mais
on découpe pas les gens en tranches mais
c'est comme ça il y a des facteurs qui
sont faciles à exprimer ceux qui sont
dans le C2P travaillent de nuit etc
travailler en équipe c'est facile vous
pouvez déterminer des points
effectivement vous savez qui a travaillé
la nuit qui travailler en équipe mais il
y a des facteurs qui sont plus complexes
c'est pas pour autant qu'on les met de
côté et notamment les facteurs
ergonomiques 80% des accidents 50% des
accidents du travail et 80% des maladies
professionnelles sont liées à des
facteurs ergonomiques c'est la raison
pour laquelle il y a une amélioration
dans ce dispositif et puis nous avons
proposé un autre dispositif qui n'était
pas non plus à l'ordre du jour c'est un
dispositif au combien important c'est
celui dans le cadre du C2P que soit pris
en compte notamment les activités
partielles pour qu'elles soient
plafonnées avant les
avant les années de retraite pour être
consacré ses activités à temps partiel
à rémunération complète en fin de
carrière de ces personnes exposées à
différents facteurs de risque de façon à
ce qu'elle puisse finir beaucoup plus
progressivement leur carrière vous voyez
ce sont des améliorations importantes
surtout quand on demande un effort pour
travailler plus longtemps il vaut mieux
terminer de façon progressive c'est une
mesure de prévention plus importante que
la mesure de réparation actuellement
c'est un agent anticipé et les
travailleurs choisissent la genticiper
parce qu'il y voit effectivement une
sortie plus précoce mais c'est pas un
service qu'on leur rend il vaut mieux
éviter qu'il reste trop longtemps sous
des facteurs d'usure et de pénibilité
c'est la raison pour laquelle les
dispositifs sont particulièrement
importants donc je souhaite je souhaite
vivement monsieur le ministre et vous le
savez on s'en est entretenu que nos
propositions soient pris en compte et
cette inscription en ce qui concerne
l'amendement des facteurs chimiques
directement ouvert qu'il soit ouvert
pour la prise en compte ces facteurs
chimiques au fond d'investissement est
un aimant tout à fait important et
j'attends monsieur le ministre votre
engagement par rapport à cette
disposition je vous remercie
merci monsieur le rapporteur bon
le temps de réorganiser nos
débats et l'ordre des amendements et des
sous amendements je vais suspendre la
séance pour 5 minutes la séance est
suspendue
la séance est reprise
mes chers collègues monsieur mise sur
l'amendement de la commission de la
commission le numéro 2132 je suis saisi
des sous amendements 5500 à 5654
c'est sous amendement été publié sur le
dossier législatif en ligne et je donne
la parole à Monsieur le Ministre
merci beaucoup monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs
j'ai souvenir hier soir lorsque nous
sommes quittés tôt ce matin il était un
peu plus d'une heure que le dérouleur
affiché 1037 amendements restants
et par curiosité ce matin lorsque je me
suis réveillé j'ai regardé où on était
le dérouleur nous étions à 1250 200 sous
amendements avaient été déposés pendant
la nuit et puis tout au fil de cette
journée vous avez des battu examinés
voter un nombre conséquent d'amendements
mais comme vous pouvez le constater le
dérouleur
continue d'augmenter
c'est une forme de vie sans fin nous
avons regardé
nous avons regardé
nous avons regardé les sous amendements
qui ont été déposés certains ont été
défendus d'autres ont été retirés
d'autres enfants ont été rejetés nous
avons eu des séries d'amendements de
sous amendements pardonnez-moi qui par
exemple lorsque une demande de rapport a
été formulée avec une date de remise au
1er avril 2024 les sous amendements 20
fois 30 fois proposé que plutôt que le
1er avril ça serait le 2 avril puis le 3
avril puis le 4 avril puis le 5 avril
nous avons eu il y a un instant
communication
des sous amendements monsieur le
Président que vous avez évoqué sur cette
amendement
sur cet amendement 21 32 de monsieur le
rapporteur il y en a je crois 150 ou 160
avec
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs il
se trouve pardonnez-moi mais depuis
quelques jours je me perfectionne dans
le règlement du Sénat et il se trouve
que la parole du gouvernement est libre
et que je peux m'exprimer comme membre
du gouvernement un moment où je souhaite
sur les sujets qui intéressent le
gouvernement
il y a
160 amendements qui est font le tour du
Dictionnaire des produits chimiques et
des agents chimiques de France c'est une
volonté manifeste d'obstruction il n'y a
pas de volonté de débat il n'y a pas de
volonté de construction il y a une
volonté de blocage et ce blocage se
mesure par les chiffres nous en sommes à
5700 ou 5800 amendement déposés
exception faite désire recevabilité et
j'ai entendu mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs socialistes votre réflexion
disons ça sera une vie sans fin ça va
monter monter monter en réalité ce que
vous voulez c'est que le Sénat soit
privé de sa capacité à voter sur le
texte
vous voulez que
le Sénat se voit confisquer sa capacité
à délibérer et à le faire
démocratiquement et d'une certaine
manière mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs vous opposez ce que vous
appelez la légitimité de la rue et la
légitimité du Parlement et nous croyons
à la légitimité du Parlement
un certain nombre
un certain nombre de présidents de
groupe un certain nombre de présidents
de groupe un certain nombre de Parlement
de sénateurs ont eu recours à
l'utilisation d'un certain nombre
d'articles du Règlement du Sénat et vous
êtes tous reconnus que si l'opposition
avait la possibilité d'utiliser le
règlement pour faire de l'obstruction
vous allez prononcé ces mots
la majorité d'autres sénateurs pouvaient
avoir recours à règlement pour garantir
un bon déroulement du débat il se trouve
que le gouvernement peut aussi le faire
et donc en application l'article 44
alinéa 2 de la Constitution le
Gouvernement s'oppose à l'examen de
l'ensemble des sous amendements déposés
sur la mandement 21 32 de monsieur le
rapporteur qui n'ont pas été soumis à
l'examen de la Commission
si
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le ministre mes chers collègues
conformément à l'article 44 alinéa 2 de
la Constitution et l'article 46 bis
alinéa 4 du règlement
le gouvernement s'oppose à l'examen des
sous amendements à l'amendement 2132 qui
n'ont pas été antérieurement soumis à la
commission même la présidente de la
commission
confirmez-vous que l'ensemble de ces
sous amendements n'ont pas été soumis
antérieurement à la commission avant
l'ouverture du débat bien évidemment
monsieur le Président je confirme
puisque ces amendements ne figurez pas
dans avant l'ouverture du débat donc
n'ont pas été soumis à l'examen de la
Commission
merci madame la Présidente dans ces
conditions c'est sous amendement ne
peuvent être examinés
et donc je vais demander l'avis du
Gouvernement sur l'amendement 2132
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Président Monsieur le rapporteur
s'il vous plaît s'il vous plaît mes
chers collègues la parole est à Monsieur
le Ministre merci monsieur le Président
un mot monsieur le Président pour dire
que le Gouvernement partage pleinement
partage pleinement la préoccupation de
la Commission sur la prévention du
risque chimique les obligations du Code
de travail qui prévoit la suppression
des expositions aux agents les plus
dangereux pour ceux pour d'autres la
limitation au minimum possible en
mettant neuf toutes les moyennes
protection disponibles sont notre
boussole en la matière et l'inspection
du travail en aspire le respect au
quotidien le quatrième plan santé au
travail qui renforce les actions de
prévention sur le terrain contre le
risque chimique et je rappelle que les
TPE peuvent via les CARSAT obtenir des
aides financières pour cela les
conventions d'objectif et de gestion la
branche à TP sont autant d'outils nous
mobilisons à la matière
il y a 22 000 substances enregistrées au
niveau européen avec des situations
d'exposition des normes d'expositions
maximum qui sont extrêmement variées et
de la pétrochimie au coiffeur en passant
par les employés de la propreté de
nombreux salariés français sont
potentiellement concernés le
gouvernement mais monsieur le rapporteur
le sait et extrêmement réservé sur
l'extension
du financement du fond d'investissement
dans la prévention l'usure
professionnelle à la question des agents
chimiques pourquoi cette réserve pour
deux raisons d'abord nous considérons
que la meilleure prévention en la
matière c'est de respecter les normes
limitant le niveau d'exposition et de
respecter les interdictions et nous ne
sommes pas dans un champ de prévention
nous sommes dans un champ de sécurité la
deuxième prévention tient en fait que
aujourd'hui les employeurs ont une
obligation qui est celle d'assurer la
sécurité de leurs employés et dans ce
cadre doivent à la fois respecter les
normes d'exposition tout comme ils
doivent respecter les normes
d'interdiction lorsque les agents
chimiques sont particulièrement
dangereux
les mêmes employeurs ont une obligation
en matière d'équipement professionnel de
sécurité
personnel et collectif pour limiter cela
et le gouvernement ne souhaiterait pas
évidemment que le fipu puisse être
mobilisé pour financer des équipements
de protection individuelle qui relèvent
d'une obligation de protection des
employeurs aujourd'hui et il nous paraît
assez tenu de c'est difficile de définir
un champ relativement ténus nous le
pensons d'intervention du FIP puis en
matière d'usure professionnelle sur la
question des agents chimiques à part
peut-être la question de la formation au
titre de la prévention n'en aucun cas
les éléments de sécurité qui sont d'ores
et déjà à la charge des employeurs dans
le cadre de cette obligation c'est la
raison pour laquelle mais vous le savez
monsieur le rapporteur nous avions cette
réserve que c'est plutôt une demande de
retrait je sais que l'amendement était
adopté par la commission des affaires
sociales donc je fais valoir cette
position en ayant bien conscience que
une grande part se débat continuera dans
le cadre de la navette parlementaire
merci monsieur le ministre
oui madame la Présidente assassin
pardon merci monsieur le Président c'est
un rappel au règlement qui se font sur
un article auquel nous avons eu recours
à plusieurs reprises
ce soir je vais essayer d'être
sereine mais je dois dire qu'après
l'annonce que nous a faite monsieur le
ministre du socle sincèrement nous ne
sommes pas surpris encore une fois
en fait vous êtes très prévisible
avec ce recours au 44 2 puis pourquoi
pas demain au 44 3 le gouvernement peut
user effectivement de cet article de de
la de la Constitution donc mais là vous
êtes prévisible alors sachez que nous ne
sommes pas dupe nous ne sommes pas comme
il a été dit lors de la conférence des
présidents mercredi matin des perdreaux
de l'année donc voilà nous sommes prêts
donc après la majorité de droits de
sénatoriales qui a je dois dire usé de
toutes les procédures que lui permet le
règlement pratiquement toutes les
procédures vous savez bien monsieur
caoutchi que lui parler permet le
règlement donc c'est maintenant au
gouvernement avec bien évidemment le
soutien de la majorité
sénatorial qui nous bâillonne alors
sincèrement que vous dire on vous a dit
déjà tellement de choses sinon que
ce que vous faites ce soir la majorité
du gouvernement est pour nous un signe
de faiblesse politique vous êtes faible
politiquement et un signe de fébrilité
aussi du gouvernement
parce qu'il sait il sait que ça réforme
est rejetée majoritairement dans le pays
elle est rejetée par cette opposition
sénatoriale et elle est rejeter
majoritairement dans le pays et ça vous
met très très mal à l'aise tout
simplement parce que cette réforme est
injuste donc c'est encore un c'est à
nouveau coup de force co-organisé je
voudrais dire qui va rejaillir Mesdames
et Messieurs les parlementaires de la
majorité dans les mobilisations qui
auront lieu samedi prochain
merci monsieur le Président rappeller au
Règlement sur le règlement 44 44 bis
déjà vous rappelez quand même que
j'avais demandé rappel au règlement
avant la suspension je l'ai demandé à la
reprise et que vous me la donnez enfin
mais voilà ça fait quand même deux fois
une première chose on a déjà fait on a
été mis en cause directement en tout cas
moi je l'ai pris pour voilà c'était cité
les présidents de groupe par monsieur le
rapporteur sur le fait qu'on ne
resterait respecterait pas un accord
donc moi ça ça me choque
particulièrement
quel accord en tout cas moi je n'ai
signé aucun accord voilà donc je pense
qu'à un moment donné il faut peut-être
remettre les choses très clairement moi
je n'ai signé aucun accord voilà oui oui
non mais vous pouvez voilà parce que
sinon ça serait grave sinon ça serait
grave voilà donc je pense qu'il faut
peut-être faut peut-être un moment de
redevenir un petit peu redescendre sur
terre voilà qu'on reprenne un débat
parlementaire un peu ensuite monsieur le
ministre moi je veux bien monsieur le
ministre que vous donniez
des
conseils on va dire
au parlementaire sur leur manière de
fonctionner mais vous dites oui les
amendements augmentent on n'avance pas
moi je constate quand même une chose
parce que je pense que c'est toujours
bien de remettre les choses à leur place
depuis le début jusqu'à l'article 7 on a
avancé on a débattu on a débattu
sereinement et c'est pas moi qui le dit
je regardais je regardais l'ensemble des
médias des articles qui louaient
justement le travail du Sénat sérieux
serein qui avançait et puis qu'est-ce
qui s'est passé il s'est passé cette
nuit du 7 au 8 cette nuit du 7 au 8 je
pense qu'il restera dans les mémoires et
là c'est pas du bon côté dans des
mémoires tristes du Sénat
vous avez voulu muselé le débat vous
avez voulu aller peut-être plus vite que
la musique vous avez voulu nous obliger
à nous censurer parce que c'était une
censure du travail parlementaire et ben
oui sauf que ben voilà merci chers
collègues
le temps était coulé chers collègues
merci à vous
monsieur chanterelle
rappelle au règlement selon l'article 44
bis
donc monsieur le ministre tout d'abord
pour vous expliquer les raisons de ces
sous-amendements nous avons sous-amendé
parce qu'il faut se rappeler quand même
que tout ça a démarré à partir de
l'article 7 où il y a plus de 1000
amendements que nous avions déposé et
qui ont été par des manœuvres justement
supprimées et depuis le début nous
souhaitons débattre sur le fond c'est
pour ça que nous redéposerons des sous
amendements pour pouvoir débattre chose
que vous n'avez pas voulu faire sur
l'article 7 ensuite je sais que monsieur
le ministre c'est difficile le débat
parlementaire pour vous parce que ici au
Sénat il n'y a pas de 49.3 donc ici nous
débattons justement vous pouvez pas nous
imposer ce type de procédure je me doute
que ça vous dérange de ne pas pouvoir
brutalité le Sénat comme vous brutalisez
l'Assemblée nationale mais ce que nous
avons assisté aussi parce qu'il faut que
les Français le sachent nous avons vu
pendant cette suspension qui devait être
de 5 minutes monsieur Retailleau et
Monsieur dussope main dans la main qui
sont sortis de la séance pour décider
ensemble d'activer cet article de la
Constitution
il faudra s'en souvenir également que la
droite et le gouvernement a décidé
d'utiliser cet article de la
Constitution contre son propre sa propre
assemblée ce soir avec le gouvernement
main dans la main maintenant les
Français ne pourront plus vous être dupe
ça a été clair et transparent
merci cher collègue madame vanne egg
monsieur le Président rappelle le
règlement sur selon l'article 44 bis
monsieur le ministre vous rejetez nos
sous amendements vous refusez le vrai
débat sur la pénibilité alors que c'est
ce qu'attend de maintenant de nous tous
les salariés exposés c'est vrai qu'il
est plus facile d'éviter les sujets qui
fâchent que de les aborder
courageusement et les affronter
courageusement chers collègues de la
majorité et monsieur le ministre nous
assistons à une démonstration de
l'acheter de mépris vis-à-vis des
Français que vous avez déjà condamnés à
travailler deux ans de plus et qui
attendent maintenant à tout le moins que
nous nous penchions sur leurs conditions
de travail et de santé au travail merci
chers collègues le président kaner
chez le Président Monsieur les ministres
le parlementarisme rationalisé
c'est
la manière dont les rédacteurs de la
Cinquième République ont envisagé de
mettre le Parlement
sous une forme de contrôle par le
gouvernement avec différents articles ça
a été d'ailleurs modifié par la réforme
de Nicolas Sarkozy en 2008
il faut le noter vous utilisez monsieur
le ministre le 44 2 vous n'avez pas de
49,3 heureusement vis-à-vis du Sénat
mais il est vrai que non pas non plus le
droit d'une motion de censure dans cette
Haute Assemblée vous auriez pu aussi
utiliser le 44 3 je crois que c'est ma
collègue à châssis qu'il a évoqué à
savoir un vote bloqué clair et net en
disant mais écoutez voilà on vote le 21
32 et on arrête les débats c'est
peut-être d'ailleurs la prochaine étape
que vous envisagez sans nous le dire
nous voyons cette gradation de plus en
plus forte pour nous empêcher encore une
fois de faire notre travail c'est à dire
de vous apporter la contradiction et de
vous apporter l'opposition face
notamment à cette réforme dont nous ne
voulons pas et vous le savez vous la
voulez et nous voyons cette encore une
fois cette coalition
qui n'est même plus de fait qui est
maintenant tellement évidente entre les
droites c'est l'intérieur et la droite
LGN nous le regrettons
nous pensions que nous pouvions trouver
d'autres solutions que celles que vous
avez utilisées
je tiens à vous dire Monsieur le
Ministre monsieur les ministres mes
chers collègues de la droite sénatoriale
que nous n'allons pas nous démparer et
que nous allons continuer à défendre nos
arguments peut-être avec moins de temps
que ce que vous auriez imaginé mais nous
le ferons avec conviction vigueur et
détermination merci chers collègues
monsieur Breuillet
merci monsieur le Président au titre de
l'article 44 bis
je
vois ce soir que le gouvernement qui a
choisi de contraindre nos débats par
l'article 47 1 et l'inscription dans un
texte de loi de finances rectificative
utilise un nouvel un nouvel article
constitutionnel pour à nouveau
contraindre nos débats et supprimer un
certain nombre d'amendements
parlementaires c'est son droit
constitutionnel le plus strict je veux
juste rappeler chers collègues que sur
tous les bancs de cette hémicycle nous
avons contesté le choix de ce véhicule
législatif qui ne permet pas ni d'avoir
la durée nécessaire au débat ni d'avoir
l'ampleur nécessaire au débat sur les
retraites et pourtant vous en êtes
accommodé et aujourd'hui vous vous
accommodez de toutes les restrictions au
droit d'expression des oppositions et je
le redis je l'ai dit tout à l'heure je
nouvelle mon propos une démocratie se
mesure au respect qu'elle donne aux
minorités en l'occurrence je pense que
ce respect vient à manquer chers
collègues le débat porte pourrons-nous
voter avant dimanche minuit moi je ne
sais pas si nous pourrons voter on vous
l'a dit à titre personnel je n'ai
d'ailleurs pas un désir fou je le dis
c'est toi soit voté puisque je m'y
oppose mais dans tous les cas qu'est-ce
qui empêchera le vote de cette loi si
elle devait être empêchée à voter c'est
l'usage du 47,1 ça n'est pas le
l'exercice de nos droits parlementaires
c'est l'usage d'un véhicule qui nous
contraint par une loi ordinaire il n'y
aurait aucun doute sur le vote enfin je
voudrais terminer en disant qu'il n'y
aura aucun doute sur le vote car si nous
votons avant dimanche minuit vous serez
satisfait que ce texte soit voté si nous
ne votions pas avant dimanche minuit
parce que nos débats se prolonge et bien
dans ce cas là vous voterez après CMP et
le Sénat il n'y a aucun problème sur le
sujet approuvera
monsieur le président rotaïo
merci monsieur le président
depuis le départ
nous divergeons sur cette réforme vous
êtes des farouches opposants et vous
vous battez avec ténacité ça n'est pas
moi
qui est toujours considéré que l'honneur
de la politique c'était la défense de
ses propres convictions qui voulait vous
faire le reproche de vos propres
convictions nous avons affiché depuis le
départ et jamais nous nous sommes cachés
ce que c'est
notre habitude de nous cacher nous avons
toujours dit que cette réforme nous la
voulions puisque nous l'avions depuis 4
ans ici au Sénat simplement nous la
voulons modifier et c'est la raison pour
laquelle pour apporter ces modifications
nous voulons aller jusqu'à son terme
j'ai entendu tout à l'heure à chaque
fois de façon répétitive avec des
rappels au règlement mais nous nous
voulons discuter du fond non c'est faux
vous ne voulez pas discuter du fond vous
voulez bloquer la discussion parce que
au rythme parce qu'au rythme vous le
savez au rythme où on va on ne pourrait
pas discuter de la Transition
Professionnelle article 13 de l'article
12 de l'assurance vieillesse pour les
aidants il y en a 4 millions
des tucs des jeunes volontaires qui ont
droit aussi à leur retraite de la
revalorisation des petites retraites
vous avez construit avec
une ingéniosité et une rapidité assez
foudroyante que je veux souligner dans
cette émission une machine une machine
à bloquer le débat et à empêcher et à
empêcher les votes une machine à
obstruction qui reposait à la fois sur
des sous amendements et sur des rappels
au règlement nous ne pouvons pas le
tolérer bien sûr que dans une démocratie
parlementaire il faut le respect des
minorités mais j'exige mes chers
collègues que les droits de la minauté
ne s'imposent pas aux droits aussi de la
majorité et la démocratie c'est qu'une
majorité au bout du compte puisse voter
pour faire valoir en réalité son propre
avis c'est ce que nous voulons pour
cette réforme et nous voulons l'éclairer
complètement et jusqu'au bout on aurait
tellement mieux fait de par les
pénibilités ce soir que tous ces rappels
au règlement que vous avez répétés et
bien je vous le dis l'obstruction c'est
la maladie
du parlementarisme c'est une maladie
l'obstruction et merci monsieur le
Président merci bien madame Ferret m'a
amer
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le Président rappeller au
règlement au titre de l'article 44 bis
je veux vous demander monsieur le
ministre et mes chers collègues de ce
côté-ci du de l'hémicycle de quoi vous
qu'est-ce que voulez-vous pardon que
voulez-vous vous voulez nous empêcher de
parler de débattre mais de quoi
avez-vous peur que craignez-vous le
gouvernement ne veut pas entendre les
milliers de Français qui rejettent cette
réforme et la majorité sénatoriale ce
soir enfin ce soir une fois de plus ne
veut pas entendre les sénateurs qui
s'opposent à cette réforme vous ne
voulez pas nous laisser débattre mais je
veux vous dire mais je veux vous dire
mes chers collègues que nous nous
voulons débattre contrairement à ce qui
est affirmé nous voulons débattre nous
avons des propositions concrètes des
propositions qui enrichissent ce débat
et vous dire pourquoi nous sommes contre
cette réforme alors je vous le dis tout
net je vous le dis tout net vous ne
réussirez pas à nous décourager et nous
serons là encore demain après une main
et après-demain et jusqu'à minuit s'il
le faut nous serons là vous nous dit que
je découragerai pas si chers collègues
monsieur Kerrouche
le président monsieur le ministre mes
chers collègues sur la base toujours de
l'article 46 bis du de notre de notre
règlement tout à l'heure à la Richard
nous a dit que le droit était une
logique c'est pas vrai moi qui suis
politique je peux vous le dire le droit
c'est simplement un outil un outil que
vous avez décidé ce soir d'utiliser
contre la minorité contre les bandes
gauche de ce de cette émission
ce qui est problématique dans votre
démarche c'est que quand on les compare
le Parlement français est l'un des
parlements les plus faibles par rapport
au pouvoir qui lui sont attribués quand
on compare à toutes les autres
démocraties occidentales et là vous
concourrez tout seul à encore
infantilisé et à diminuer le rôle du
Parlement c'est ce que vous êtes en
train de faire parce que parce que vous
vous êtes mis vous parlementaire dans la
main du gouvernement
c'est ce que vous avez fait
et vous renoncez à tous vos droits alors
effectivement monsieur le Président
Retailleau nous sommes frontalement
opposés à cette réforme autant que vous
la voulez mais
on aurait pu faire plus intelligent vous
nous reprochez les sous-amendements
parce que vous avez supprimé tous nos
amendements de suppression et je vous le
dis très tranquillement c'est
l'équilibre de la terreur à chaque fois
que vous chercherez à nous marcher
dessus à nous brutaliser nous trouverons
des moyens et je vais vous le dire très
tranquillement mes chers collègues ça
nous pose aucune difficulté parce que
derrière nous nous sommes portés par des
milliers des millions de Françaises qui
nous regardent et qu'ils ne veulent pas
de cette réforme et nous
nous ici nous sommes leur représentants
pour vous dire non pour vous dire merci
chers collègues
la parole est à Monsieur Assouline
oui rappelle au règlement article 44 bis
monsieur Retailleau
le Parlement et le parlementarisme ne
vient pas de naître
ici j'ai connu un parlement qui a eu des
batailles mémorables sur la laïcité
d'autres nous avions cinq minutes
d'explications de vote 5 minutes pour
présenter un amendement et 5 minutes
pour intervention paroles sur article on
a fait plus plusieurs semaines de débats
sur une réforme des retraites en 2010 de
la même nature c'était deux ans de plus
pour les travailleurs de ce pays
et nous avons été au bout et nous avons
utilisé plus de temps que le temps qui
est un parti aujourd'hui alors que cette
fois-ci il est contraint c'est dimanche
soir
donc
le problème n'est pas
chez nous monsieur Retailleau le
problème il est que le gouvernement a
décidé avec l'article 47 1 de la
constitution de limiter ce débat et vous
qui voulez aller au vote d'accord vous
acceptez cette imitation demandez-leur
de lever ça
et on ira au bout il y aura un vote
donc vous avez accepté alors que vous
êtes des parlementaires qui devaient
contrôler et tempérer
les volontés de l'exécutif de toujours
se passer de trop de débats
parlementaires vous avez décidé d'être
supplétif de l'exécutif contre le
Parlement
c'est ça la réalité c'est ça la réalité
et donc nous
nous considérons que à la base de la
démocratie de la République le
parlementarisme c'est la liberté des
députés et des sénateurs de contrôler le
gouvernement de débattre d'amender et
d'expliquer leur vote merci chers
collègues madame Lubin
et 44 bis monsieur le sénateur
Retailleau sur le président Retailleau
pardon vous avez souligné votre vous
avez souligné votre respect des des élus
qui ont des convictions et qui les
défendent et je vous enseignerai
moi je m'exprime ce soir en tant que
chef de fil de mon groupe sur ce sujet
sur le dossier des retraites c'est un
dossier qui me passionne c'est un
dossier qui me tient particulièrement à
cœur
tout comme au membre de mon groupe et
j'ai réussi à les entraîner derrière ma
passion parce que
j'ai chevillé au corps l'envie de
défendre
des gens modestes des ouvriers des
salariés des gens avec qui je vis
toujours voilà et vraiment porter non je
ne vous fais aucune critique je parle
juste de mon histoire de mon expérience
personnelle c'est tout je fais pas de
critique et je me suis engagée à
défendre ce en quoi je crois
profondément pour tous ces salariés tous
ces tous ces gens là voilà je l'ai fait
et j'ai entraîné vraiment mon groupe
derrière moi parce qu'il se peut que
nous n'ayons pas eu tous forcément au
début la même conviction alors moi je
vous le dis très clairement monsieur le
Président Retailleau je souhaite aider
battre jusqu'au bout j'avais envie de
débattre de l'article 7 nous avait un
peu coupé les ailes mais on a quand même
réussi à le faire j'avais envie de
débattre de l'article 8 et vous avez pu
voir toute cette journée que nous en
avons débattu et de manière qualitative
je vous assure que j'ai envie de
débattre de ensuite de la pénibilité de
l'article 10 avec ces fameux 1200 euros
si si je vous assure que j'ai envie de
débattre de tout ça alors vous voyez et
je vais terminer là-dessus laissez-nous
faire les si vous n'aviez pas entamer ce
que vous avez entamé nous aurions déjà
fait la moitié de l'article 9
la parole est un monsieur Hainaut
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre avec
gravité moi je vais aller un peu plus
loin monsieur Kerrouche je pense que
votre volonté d'opposition à la réforme
et peut-être plus forte que notre
volonté de voter cette réforme eh oui
mais seulement pour nous il y a quelque
chose qui est sacré et c'est à la
différence de vous ce sont les
institutions il Sénat ah oui si si oui
oui c'est sacré cette chose là et vous
jouez avec les allumettes vous jouez
avec les allumettes car le Parlement je
vous ai beaucoup écouté le Parlement
pardonnez-moi je vous ai beaucoup écouté
mais non monsieur kaner vous êtes mal à
l'aise depuis le début monsieur Kanner
parce que vous êtes déposé dépassé par
votre base radicale mais laissez-nous
parler autrement vous feriez pas ça
alors un peu de silence un peu de
respect
vous respirez le mal-être vous respirez
le mal-être monsieur caner vous respirez
le mal-être mais pour nous les
institutions elles sont sacrées elles
sont sacrées oh là là elles sont sacrées
le Parlement c'est débattre on veut
débattre mais il y a une différence
entre vous et nous depuis le début c'est
que nous on veut débattre mais on veut
voter voter c'est ça aussi le Parlement
votez et depuis le début vous faites
tout pour nous empêcher de voter de nous
exprimer voilà et voyez il y a peut-être
une arrière-pensée parce qu'il y a
toujours des arrières pensées en
politique
l'arrière-pensée c'est que vous vous
dites on va peut-être tirer les
bénéfices
de cette crise ou cette difficulté mais
c'est pas vous détrompez-vous c'est le
populisme et les populistes qui vont
tirer les bénéfices et donc nous on est
attaché au Sénat aux institutions à la
démocratie représentative c'est la
raison pour laquelle on est solidaire
avec le président du Sénat il faut
débattre et voter voilà l'essentiel je
vous remercie merci chers collègues
président Laurent
[Applaudissements]
écoutez ça fait maintenant deux heures
que nous attendons d'entrer dans le
débat sur l'article 9 et nous y allons
et nous allons oui et nous allons y
entrer par la plus petite porte qui soit
avec l'amendement que vous appelez
appelé en priorité alors que je l'ai dit
tout à l'heure c'est un article majeur
de la loi et que le sujet de la
pénibilité est attendu par tous ceux qui
nous regardent donc deux heures de perdu
par vos procédures celles déclenchées
d'abord par la droite sénatoriale et la
commission ensuite par le gouvernement
on Accor avec la droite sénatoriale
je voudrais dire deux choses monsieur le
ministre vous avez évoqué le tableau des
amendements ils ne sont plus affichés il
y avait 5238 amendements
il en reste 1126 autrement dit nous en
avons examiné
80%. il reste devant nous il reste si
80%, il reste devant nous trois jours et
deux nuits pour discuter
et encore seulement ça parce que vous
avez parce que le gouvernement a fixé
une limite donc au rythme où nous
avançons il n'y a aucune raison de
penser à cette heure que nous
n'arriverons pas au terme du débat ça
c'est vous qui le décrétez en vérité
vous êtes en train de mettre en scène
depuis mardi crescendo la montée au
régime de procédures pour bâillonner le
débat c'est tout ce que vous faites et
c'est vous qui empêchez le débat et je
voudrais dire à mes collègues de la
droite qu'il devrait méditer parce que
vous avez décidé d'être le jouet
consentant du gouvernement dans cette
affaire et bien vous devriez méditer ce
que disait un ancien président des
républicains Christian Jacob on n'est
pas obligé d'être la droite la plus bête
du monde
Richard collègues monsieur Lecomte
merci monsieur le Président c'est un
rappel le règlement au titre de
l'article 44 bis du règlement de notre
assemblée
voyez-vous je ne suis pas un spécialiste
du sujet j'arrive avec des convictions
j'arrive avec des interrogations
j'arrive aussi avec les spécificités des
problèmes spécifiques que les personnes
les Françaises et les Français que je
représente ont et vous le savez ils sont
ils vivent à l'étranger et ont des
difficultés spécifiques par rapport à ce
projet
nous avons eu des moments où beaucoup
de mes amis politiques ont exprimé leurs
interrogations et la condamnation de ce
projet d'une manière globale toutefois
depuis deux jours nous observons un
certain nombre d'échanges très fructueux
entre nos spécialistes et au premier
titre desquels nos chefs de fil à gauche
je voudrais donner rendre un hommage
particulier à Madame poncemonge qui suit
l'ensemble du débat et les échanges qui
puisent avoir entre nos chefs de fil et
notre rapporteur qui effectivement
enrichissent le débat et pourtant voilà
ça débat ça ça dérape et aujourd'hui à
un moment essentiel quand on arrive sur
la pénibilité vous arrivez avec des des
manières d'interpréter le règlement donc
on nous dit par exemple dans le
règlement Arctic 46 bis les amendements
sont mis au vote dans leur ci-après les
amendements de suppression et ensuite
les amendements commençant par ceux qui
s'écartent le plus du texte proposé que
vous nous proposez de faire autrement
vous arrivez avec des amendements qui
sont pas des amendements qui sont
anecdotiques par rapport à l'ensemble de
la question de la pénibilité question de
labilité de pénibilité dont vous savez
parfaitement que c'est pas l'essentiel
de préoccupation du gouvernement puisque
il y a eu l'ordonnance qui a supprimé
les dispositions qui avaient été volées
pendant la loi Touraine alors voyez-vous
il serait préférable de reprendre ses
esprits et de reprendre la manière de
travailler que nous avions pas de jouer
au bac à sable pas de dire vous avez
commencé ou autre voilà je crois que
nous étions rentrés dans un moment où
nous pouvions rentrer et laisser
finalement le dialogue entre spécialiste
et pas revenir à ça voilà et monsieur le
rapporteur monsieur le rapporteur
monsieur le rapporteur nous avons encore
3 jours connaître arrêtons merci la
parole est à Monsieur Dantec
merci merci monsieur le Président ça
sera donc un rappel au règlement au
titre de l'article 44 bis moi je
voudrais quand même ce soir rendre
hommage au père de la Constitution
parce qu'ils ont quand même énormément
réfléchi sur ce qui était le Sénat le
Sénat c'est pas l'Assemblée nationale
l'Assemblée nationale 49-3 on vient on
voit bien la logique un gouvernement qui
s'impose à sa majorité quand elle est un
peu frondeuse même si c'est toujours
dangereux d'utiliser le 49-3 l'histoire
politique de ces dernières années là
quand même montré y compris avec
d'autres gouvernements mais
ceux qui ont inventé cette constitution
qu'ils ont réfléchi sont dit le Sénat ça
peut pas être ça au Sénat on ne peut pas
passer en force ça n'existe pas
au Sénat dès que quelqu'un prend un
élément du règlement pour essayer de
gagner du temps il y a dans l'article
d'à côté l'antidote et comme on connaît
tous à peu près le règlement enfin là on
a tous beaucoup progressé quand même
dans la connaissance du règlement depuis
quelques jours et ben ça ne peut pas
marcher c'est impossible donc après ça
peut être soit on décide que c'est une
bataille médiatique pour savoir qui va
porter la responsabilité du fait qu'on
n'est pas allé au bout soit on se dit
respectons le Sénat le Sénat débat point
bas c'est pas la peine de sortir du 38
du 42 de tout ce qu'on veut si on veut
aller au bout il faut laisser au
sénateur tout le temps et il y a
quelqu'un dans cette salle qui peut
laisser tout le temps au Sénat de
débattre c'est le gouvernement il n'y a
absolument pas nécessité d'arrêter
dimanche soir si le gouvernement veut
qu'on débatte on prend une semaine de
plus et là on ira au bout et on commence
évidemment par retirer l'amendement du
rapporteur Savary pour reprendre l'ordre
normal des choses et on ira au bout mais
on ne brutalise pas le Sénat celui qui
cherche à trouver dans le règlement des
raisons d'accélérer il pèse
merci monsieur le Président alors notre
groupe nous enfin nous notre groupe
écologiste nous avons déposé des
amendements jusqu'au dernier article et
on aimerait bien effectivement que ces
amendements de fonds soient discutés et
quand on aime le travail quand on dit
que c'est une valeur on ne le gâche pas
la première chose que vous appellera et
vous appellerait vous direz le monde
ouvrier c'est que le travail ça se
respecte et on ne le gâche pas alors je
vous dire une chose vous avez fait
tomber des amendements de fond vous ne
les avez fait tomber par diverses
mesures je n'y reviens pas et vous nous
avez obligé de faire des sous
amendements de moindre qualité j'en
conviens il fallait laisser nos
amendements de fond mais dès le début
dès le début je l'ai dit en commission
des affaires sociales un débat il se
débat là devait être dans une loi
ordinaire dès le début je l'avais dit
dans dans elle devait être précédé d'une
loi travail donc dès le début et je l'ai
dit en commission ça ne tiendra pas dans
le la seringue du temps contraint que
vous avez accepté vous êtes soumis à ce
temps alors il faut pas moi je dis que
jamais nous le groupe écologiste même
dans une majorité on se serait soumis à
ce que vous vous êtes
soumis voilà non c'est pas notre genre
donc à partir de là je veux dire bon là
vous êtes là vous êtes en train de vous
batailler pour qui dire qui a la
paternité de cette loi mais vous deux il
y a deux pairs le parent le père 1 le
père d'eux voilà le parent le parent en
deux oh là là vous étiez contre le
parois un par deux mais là ça s'applique
donc bon je veux dire il faut être
sérieux si vous vouliez un débat sérieux
fallait pas je commencer dès le début
arrondir des articles des amendements
qu'il était pas donc vous avez le
monnaie de la pièce c'est tout et chers
collègues madame Cohen
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le Président toute la
journée je pense que nous avons débattu
de manière sérieuse de manière
argumentée notamment sur l'article 8 et
les choses se sont passées sereinement
comme on a l'habitude au niveau du Sénat
passionnément
argument contre argument mais sans sans
que il y ait une perte de temps
particulière je fais référence à
dimanche matin dimanche matin nous avons
eu un débat de fond sur capitalisation
là encore projet contre projet de droite
contre projet de gauche et en fait on se
bat au niveau des bandes de gauche sur
une réforme qui a été qui veut être
imposé à la hussarde contre la vie du
peuple contre la vie des organisations
syndicales avec un front uni de toutes
les organisations syndicales qui
demandent un rendez-vous avec le
président de la République parce qu'ils
veulent être entendus et ici
finalement alors que ça se passait sur
le fond et bien vous dégainer de
procédures d'abord au niveau des de la
droite sénatoriale en parfaite
complicité avec le gouvernement puis le
gouvernement s'emmène par les voies la
voix du ministre et vous vous étonnez
que finalement ça se passe mal on ne
discute plus du fond on fait des appels
au règlement on fait des scrutins
publics parce que finalement on en a le
droit en tant que parlementaire mais
vous nous faites perdre du temps à tous
et à toutes ça n'est pas grave ça n'est
pas grave ce qui est grave c'est que
vous méprisez les gens parce que cette
réforme elle a des conséquences très
extrêmes sur la vie des gens vous leur
volez deux ans d'existence vous vous en
fichez ça fait quatre ans que vous le
votez au PLFSS pas nous et du coup on ne
parle pas de la pénibilité on ne parle
pas des petites retraites et ça vous
amuse et ben nous ça nous amuse pas et
on va continuer à se battre pied à pied
merci chers collègues
donc sur l'amendement 21 32 j'ai été
saisi d'une demande de scrutin public
par le groupe socialiste
avec Madame pourcemonge madame Poce
oui
merci monsieur le Président alors j'ai
bien entendu monsieur le rapporteur qui
a qui a bien écouté les organisations
syndicales alors pas tout à fait
jusqu'au bout parce que qu'est-ce que
demande les organisations syndicales
depuis un moment et demande certes là
pour le fipu vous avez raison monsieur
le rapporteur elle demande que les
agents chimiques soient intégrés à côté
des trois facteurs
ergonomiques mais elles demandent aussi
et ça vous n'avait pas entendu ça c'est
l'oreille gauche que si les six facteurs
de pénibilité qui sont dans le CDP et le
droit aussi de rentrer dans le fifu elle
demande qu'effectivement le fipu pardon
intègre le dit les dix facteurs
et ça c'est très important pour eux et
c'est en miroir du fait que j'espère que
vous avez un amendement puisque vous
écoutez les organisations syndicales le
fait que les organisations syndicales
demandent que le C2P comprenne les 10
facteurs donc vous voyez c'est les deux
choses ils disent se font que vous créez
les 10 facteurs doivent pouvoir y être
mobiliser je suis un peu étonné par
l'argument du ministre qui dit palais
pas les chimiques parce que ils vont
acheter des équipements de protection
individuel bon c'est valable ça pour les
trois facteurs j'espère qu'on va pas
acheter des épis avec 250 millions
chaque année donc bon votre argument
pour les chimiques là j'ai pas bien
compris donc monsieur le rapporteur
puisque vous êtes à l'écoute des
organisations syndicales défendaient que
le fipu comprenne puis cette mobilisée
par les 10 facteurs de pénibilité et
qu'à l'inverse le CDB comprennent les 10
facteurs de pénibilité je vous remercie
merci
[Musique]
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues
effectivement madame et monsieur le
rapporteur il fallait remettre ce
chrétien de pénibilité pardon concernant
les agents chimiques dangereux ce
rétablissement est absolument nécessaire
la suppression de ce critère de
pénibilité en 2017 était une aberration
totale et proprement scandaleuse en
effet nous avons dépassé la sixième
limite planétaire sur l'arrivée de
nouvelles espèces chimiques sur le
marché et donc dans l'environnement et
celle-ci était exponentielle la terre
n'en peut plus mais et bien sûr les
risques professionnels provoqués par
leur fabrication leur manipulation sont
on ne peut plus importants et réels en
plus il y a de nouveaux produits sur le
marché et plus nous il y a de nouveaux
produits pardon plus nous devons les
prendre en compte je voterai donc cet
amendement mais il n'est pas suffisant
il fallait réintégrer les autres
critères de pénibilité qui ont été
supprimés en 2017 vous rendez vous
compte de ce qu'il représente pour des
salariés qui les vivent quotidiennement
ils ne sont pas des moindres manip
manutention manuelle de charge posture
pénible définie comme position forcée
des articulations vibrations mécaniques
il me semble qu'ils ne sont pas vraiment
rétablis cette pénibilité est-elle
négligeable anecdotique cette pénibilité
ne mérite-t-elle pas des dispositions
particulières pour les travailleurs
concernés plus les débats avancent et
plus il confirme que vous vivez vraiment
dans un autre monde un autre pays un
pays où le travail n'est pas pénible et
où l'espérance de vie et la même pour
tous ce n'est pas le cas largement
pouvons-nous à notre époque
raisonnablement dans le monde qui est le
nôtre qualifié de ce qui est qualifié de
société avancée nier que nombre de nos
concitoyens et concitoyens travaillent
dans des conditions difficiles voient
extrêmement difficile les régressions de
2017 devaient être abolies et il lui
fallut aller voir de plus près les
nouvelles pénibilités Laurent
c'est amendement est à nos yeux
extrêmement insuffisant il ne nous
convient ni sur la forme ni sur le fond
il nous fait entrer comme je le disais
tout à l'heure par la plus petite des
portes dans un débat essentiel que nous
aurions dû avoir
sur la pénibilité bien sûr il réintègre
un critère sur les matières dangereuses
et nous n'y sommes pas insensibles bien
au contraire
mais il laisse à l'écart tous les autres
critères de pénibilité qui ont été
exclus
de de la loi et il ne les réintègre pas
donc c'est pour solde de tout compte en
quelque sorte cette amendement alors que
le débat devrait être largement ouvert
plus au fond il évacue d'autant qu'il a
été présenté en priorité pour faire
tomber tout le reste du débat il évacue
le débat fondamental qui substitue à la
notion de pénibilité celle d'usure
professionnelle ça n'est pas du tout la
même chose et c'est ce que les syndicats
contestent
parce que en changeant de termes il n'y
a plus pour vous de métier pénible que
des salariés doivent exercer et qui en
échange de cela sont compensés y compris
dans leur droit à la traite il n'y a
plus que des salariés plus ou moins
résistants à l'usure professionnelle ça
n'est pas du tout la même chose parce
que dans la deuxième vision en gros on
les use autant qu'on peut et on voit ce
qui reste avant la retraite dans le
meilleur des cas pour voir si
éventuellement on fait une compensation
c'est donc une logique diamétralement
opposée et c'est la logique que conteste
les syndicats et le fond qui est créé il
y a beaucoup de problèmes que j'espère
nous arriverons quand même à discuter je
ne sais pas si nous pourrons le faire
pour qui se font pour les retraités non
pour financer les entreprises et leurs
dépenses de prévention
éventuellement
au retraités
mes chers collègues concernant cet
amendement si on peut satisfaire que le
rapporteur évoque ce critère de
pénibilité en particulier au travers de
cet amendement nous souhaitons indiquer
que la proposition d'inclure ce critère
dans le fond d'investissement prévention
de l'usure professionnelle et
insuffisant car c'est bien dans le C2P
qu'il faut réintroduire ce critère c'est
bien ainsi que comme cela était le cas
avant 2017 et bien que les agents et les
salariés par non qui sont confrontés à
ce critère pourront je dirais bénéficier
de mesures particulières et notamment
une prise en compte par rapport à une
fin de carrière plus rapide donc au
regard de ces éléments nous nous
affirmerons sur cet amendement merci
président Gontard
oui merci merci monsieur le Président le
groupe écologiste aurait pu
effectivement voter cet amendement qui
vise inclure les agents chimiques
dangereux dans les facteurs pris en
compte par le fond d'investissement dans
la prévention d'usure professionnelle
créée par l'article 9 et vous voyez bien
que on peut pas prendre cet élément
indépendamment et qu'on avait amandé
parce que on a d'autres effectivement
facteurs de pénibilité et que on ne peut
pas voter cette amendement isolé qui en
plus fait tomber nos propres amendements
qui venaient le compléter en fait cette
réforme des retraites injuste et brutale
n'a rien d'étonnant puisqu'elle rentre
dans la continuité tout simplement de la
politique menée par Emmanuel Macron
depuis 2017 ce gouvernement choisi
d'ignorer la pénibilité la souffrance au
travail qui touche les salariés Emmanuel
Macron en 2019 avait déclaré moi je
n'adore pas le mot pénibilité parce que
ça donne le sentiment que le travail
serait pénible oui monsieur Macron pour
beaucoup de salariés le travail est
pénible et il fait souffrir car lorsque
vous êtes préparateur de commande ou
encore chef d'exposition et que vous
soulevez plusieurs tonnes de produits
par semaines à des horaires décalés de
nuit et tout cela dans un environnement
froid que vous avez des problèmes de dos
d'épaule ou encore des céréales oui le
travail est pénible en 2017 monsieur
Macron a par ailleurs supprimé 4
critères de pénibilité au travail les
postures pénibles les vibrations
mécaniques la manutation de charge
lourde et les agents chimiques dangereux
dont on parle maintenant ce dernier
critère de pénibilité de pénibilité
l'exposition aux agents chimiques
dangereux qui est concerné par cette
amendement présente des risques très
dangereux pour la santé puisqu'il
entraîne des pathologies très graves
telles que des cancers et peuvent
également provoquer des insuffisances
rénales ou des troubles de la fertilité
donc oui on aurait pu voter cette
abonnement cependant nous souhaitons
rappeler que le gouvernement peut
largement faire mieux sur ces sur ces
questions de pénibilité puisque le
compte professionnel de prévention par
exemple qui est censé justement prendre
en compte les critères de pénibilité est
un dispositif utile qui a même été
critiqué par la Cour des comptes qui le
considère comme pas à la hauteur des
objectifs qui lui était assigné
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues
l'amendement 2132 porté par Monsieur
Savary visa inclure les agents chimiques
dangereux au même titre que les facteurs
de risque ergonomique parmi les facteurs
pris en compte par le fond
d'investissement dans la prévention de
l'usure professionnelle créée par
article 9 on a compris que le
gouvernement est pas tout à fait
d'accord sur le sujet moi je pense que
pourquoi en prendre qu'un il faudrait
peut-être réintégrer tous les critères
de pénibilité qui ont été supprimés
rappelons qu'en 2017 un des premiers
actes d'Emmanuel Macron avait été de
supprimer 4 des 10 critères de
pénibilité instaurer au cours du
quinquennat de François Hollande à
savoir l'exposition au risque aux agents
chimiques dangereux la manutention
manuelle de charge les postures pénibles
les vibrations mécaniques et ce au
motifs que certains critères étaient
parfois complexes à mettre en place pour
les entreprises il est vrai que la
notion de pénibilité en elle-même ne
convient pas beaucoup au président de la
République qui déclare en 2019 moi
j'adore pas le mot de pénibilité parce
que ça donne le sentiment que le travail
serait pénible mais ne lui en déplaise
je pense qu'il est important de
réaffirmer collectivement ici que oui le
travail peut être pénible et que c'est
justement le reconnaissant qu'on peut
d'une part améliorer les conditions de
travail qui posent question et d'autres
par aménager au mieux les conditions de
départ en retraite et Monsieur Capu
merci monsieur le président
moi j'aurais aimé ce soir effectivement
on parle des Françaises et des Français
qui travaillent la nuit qui travaille
dans le froid qui travaille
à des tâches difficiles qui travaillent
en 3/8 qui soulève des patients qui
soulèvent des charges tout cela j'avais
même préparé modestement un petit mot
pour qu'on parle de tout ça parce que
c'est censé être le sujet ce soir
j'aurais aimé qu'on compare de
l'abaissement des seuils d'accessibilité
de certains critères de pénibilité
j'aurais aimé qu'on parle du
déplafonnement du nombre de points du
C2P j'aurais aimé qu'on parle de la
simplification de l'accès à la retraite
anticipée pour incapacité j'aurais aussi
aimé effectivement qu'on parle des
agents chimiques et de l'intérêt ou pas
de les introduire et au lieu de ça toute
la soirée mes chers collègues nous avons
parlé
de procédure
de la suppression d'amendements qui
étaient tous des amendements
identiques de suppression de cela
rédiger dans les mêmes termes et pour
répondre à Monsieur Kerrouche
vous n'avez pas le monopole de la
représentation des Français nous aussi
nous représentons les Français et les
Français nous aussi nous aurions aimé
parler de leur souffrance de leurs
inquiétudes vis-à-vis de la pénibilité
de leur tâches
au lieu de ça vous avez fait un calcul
ce calcul c'est le calcul de
l'obstruction vous avez fait le pari de
faire perdre du temps pour ne pas voter
ce texte c'est un pari mes chers
collègues éminemment dangereux vous
croyez faire les malins mais ça n'est
pas vous qui gagnerez c'est la
démocratie qui perdra c'est le Sénat qui
perd en crédibilité en se mélange
chemisant et en courant derrière les
extrêmes et au final au final les
Français
les Français vont être déçus de notre
parentale parlementarisme alors je
voterai cet amendement mais
malheureusement pour constater que nous
n'aurons pas pu débattre merci cher
collègue
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le Président je sais
qu'il est tard et que certains d'entre
vous semblent excédés mais je pense
qu'il faut non seulement garder son
sang-froid mais une once de crédibilité
également parce que le collègue qui
vient nous expliquer tout ce dont il
aimerait parler sur cet article mais
bien sûr que c'est de ça dont il faut
parler c'est précisément sur ces objets
que nous avons déposé des amendements
qui viennent d'être qui viennent de
d'être tous par une une énième procédure
qui viennent de tomber ça fait écho
est-ce que j'ai entendu ce matin qui ne
manquait pas de pique en non plus ou un
de nos collègues nous a expliqué qu'il
avait un amendement qui visait à
atténuer la difficulté pour les
carrières longues et croyez-le si vous
le voulez qu'il avait retiré cet
amendement qui pourtant allait apporter
les plus grands bienfaits aux personnes
concernées par ces carrières longues
parce que nous
poignée
d'élus de gauche nous allions sous
amender cet amendement mais pensez-vous
pensez-vous vraiment que les Français on
a une chance c'est que le Sénat est
regardé comme rarement dans ses débats
mais attention à ce que cette chance ne
se retourne pas en
quelque chose qui se retourne tous
contre nous parce que ce quand on dit ça
que croyez-vous que les Français pensent
ils pensent que vous vous moquez du
monde purement et simplement nous sommes
là pour amender pour supprimer les
articles que nous considérons comme
étant pas acceptable et ensuite pour
travailler à améliorer la loi nous ne
faisons rien d'autre que ça je suis
quand même un peu impressionné que ça
vous gêne à ce point
et ensuite nous passerons au vote
avec un scrutin public
excusez-moi monsieur le président
là on demande 2132 de Monsieur Savary
vise à réintégrer les produits chimiques
donc dans le cadre des critères de
pénibilité et intégrer à ce fameux forme
prévention parmi les mesures proposées
dans cet article 9 il y a donc la
création de fond d'investissement dans
la prévention de l'usure professionnelle
au sein donc de la branche ATMP visant à
prévenir l'exposition au risque
ergonomique et donc ça varie demande
qu'on y rajoute qu'on y réintègre les
dangers chimiques pardon ce fond qui
serait doté de 1 milliard d'euros
jusqu'en 2027 c'est-à-dire à peine 250
millions d'euros par an au rapport
mission de co-financer avec les
employeurs des actions de prévention
sensibilisation aménagement de poste
formation reconversion mais la
prévention nous savons bien est un enjeu
crucial pour notre système de santé le
gouvernement avait d'ailleurs parlé du
plfs lors du PFS 2023 d'un virage de la
prévention
et d'ailleurs notre miss nest de la
santé est aujourd'hui un ministre la
santé et de la prévention pourtant aucun
article ne traitait de la prévention
primaire et c'est là-dessus que je
voudrais insister la prévention primaire
c'est à dire celle qui l'a plus
importante la qualité de l'air la
qualité l'alimentation les mauvais
effets d'accidentité les bienfaits de du
sport les conditions de travail etc il
est temps que nous changions de
paradigme et que nous construisions un
modèle basé sur la santé et non sur le
soin en agissant non plus seulement sur
les maladies mais sur les déterminants
de la santé ce que l'on appelle partout
le concept de one F mais une fois encore
le gouvernement ne semble pas avoir pris
la mesure des besoins de prévention et
de son utilité pour préserver la santé
de nos concitoyens et diminuer à terme
nos dépenses de santé dans ce texte
dépense de prévention sont à un milliard
d'euros sur cinq ans et vont être
largement inférieur
à ce que va coûter le relèvement de
l'âge légal de départ à la retraite de
62 à 74 donc j'ai été saisi d'une
demande de scrutin public par le groupe
socialiste sur l'amendement 21-32 je
vous rappelle que la commission est
favorable la vie du Gouvernement est
défavorable il va être procédé au
scrutin public dans les conditions
fixées par le règlement le scrutin est
ouvert
le scrutin est clos
nombre de votants 344 exprimé 241 pour
217 contre 24 le Sénat a adopté
mes chers collègues je vais lever la
séance prochaine séance vendredi 10 mars
à 9h 30 pour la suite de l'examen du
projet de loi de financement
rectificative de la sécurité sociale
pour 2023 la séance est levée